Four,
three,
two.
Welcome back.
John Doe.
What's happening baby?
It's good to be here.
It's good to see you,
man.
We were just talking about Chris
Cornell.
We uh,
found out last night at the comedy store
that he died and then this morning and
found out that he hung himself.
Just fuck.
It's,
it's hard to even comprehend.
How do you comprehend that I'm,
I'm living in a parallel universe.
Doesn't make any sense.
Like how could someone like,
you know,
it's easy on the outside looking in like
I like that,
but you'd like that guy was one of the
best ever.
Like how does a guy like that even want
to kill himself?
How does the lead singer of soundgarden.
To me,
it just really kind of reveal.
So the complexities of human life.
Exactly what you're saying.
To have a guy that is at the pinnacle of
his skill,
the Pinnacle of fame,
the pinnacle of money,
and for him to say,
you know what?
Not gonna do it anymore.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know what was going on in his
head.
Obviously.
Who knows if he was on medication,
if he had some sort of issue health
issue,
who knows?
I mean,
I would never speculate,
but it just,
I don't understand.
I mean,
again,
I don't know his life,
but I couldn't even comprehend it.
I can't even imagine it.
Well,
that's one of the really hard things
when you start talking about suicide for
people that for someone like me and
I've,
I haven't had suicidal thoughts.
Right.
So when you,
when you go from that to somebody that
not only has the thoughts but then goes
ahead and executes it,
it's very hard to comprehend.
Yeah.
I've met people that have done it
before.
I've met.
I have added a few friends that have
done it.
I just have never understood it.
I don't get it,
but I don't know them.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's got their own unique mindset
and just,
you know,
what's really crazy,
man,
I read this statistic the other day
about suicide,
that people in poor neighborhoods are
far less likely to kill themselves.
People that are in the struggle.
Yeah.
Well,
I actually believed that because they're
fighting for something.
Yeah,
and someone that's already got
everything and then there,
then they end up with no drive with no
goal and nothing left to achieve and so
then all the sudden they're just staring
at the mirror without anywhere else to
go.
You know,
and I'm not talking about Chris Cornell
in particular,
but for some people I know one of the
things that happens is that when they
become very successful and they're still
not happy,
then they get hopeless.
They just feel like,
well I have everything and yet I'm
fucking miserable.
You know,
I have a nice big house.
I drive this fancy car and I still am
miserable.
Like there's no hope like this life is
meaningless.
I don't even know what to say to that.
I don't know what to say to be honest
with you.
When you hear you hear that,
you just don't even know what to say to
that.
You know,
one thing that,
why I don't understand it,
I like struggle.
I like.
I think it's important.
I know there's no doubt about that.
There's no doubt about having something
that you're striving for some goal and
like you just said,
when you own all those goals had been
achieved and now you're sitting there at
the top of the mountain and you now you
don't feel happy.
What do you do?
Just pick up a fucking Hobbie man.
Find something you suck at and get
better at it.
I mean,
that seems so simplistic,
but,
um,
uh,
you know,
I just,
you and I are,
we shared this a very important part of
our lives,
which is a intense exercise indeed.
And I think that,
you know,
I go to your instagram almost every day
to look at your watch.
It's hilarious.
If you go to Jockos instagram,
it's a fucking timex watch
advertisement,
but it's all at ironman watch at 4:30
in the morning,
the occasional 3:30.
This motherfucker is up at 3:30
and you know,
and you working out like this is fucking
Harry gorilla arm at a Timex ironman
triathlon watch.
But that's what's up man.
That's what's up.
I mean,
just fucking doing it,
getting out there and struggling.
And then once you do do that,
here's the thing,
like,
you know,
like a friend of mine said that I was
uh,
I was saying something about you come on
the podcast and he goes,
can that do take another picture?
I was fucking watch.
I go,
I will be,
takes a picture of his watch everyday
until he dies.
I go,
it's important.
It's important.
It's,
it's sort of in a lot of ways,
it's symbolic of what we're talking
about.
Like,
no,
it's not fun to look at your watch every
day,
but you fucking do it every day.
Like that's what's important.
Yeah.
And I actually,
early on I had someone say something
along the lines of,
on social media,
on instagram or on twitter,
you know,
oh,
you're just going to post another
picture you're watching.
I was like,
unfollow me,
just don't follow me.
It's no big deal.
I'm not making you do it.
And,
and now it is kind of turned into
something where I'm doing it everyday
regardless of anything else in the
world.
Fuck them.
I like looking at your watch.
I want to know when I get up at seven
and I think I'm getting up early.
You've been up for hours.
You already done work now.
I like it.
I think it's a,
it's,
but it is a lot of ways.
It is symbolic of what we're talking
about.
It's the struggle.
Yeah.
And you know,
you know,
who doesn't complain about and I always
make this point too.
There's like a,
a single mom somewhere in the valley
here that's working three jobs that's
getting up at 3:30
in the morning so she can go work as a
waitress somewhere before she's got her
other day job that she's got to go
through so she can feed her kids.
I get up almost as a luxury at this
point.
I mean I'm,
I'm a retired guy from the,
from the military,
so I can kind of get up whenever I want.
I get up early as a luxury sort of.
But you also get up because that's who
you are.
Yeah.
And I get up because it is,
it is a way to maintain discipline in
life for sure.
The kit that stone out and sharpen that
blade every morning show.
It's the grind that sharpens the acs.
Indeed just no other way.
There's no other way.
And I don't want to say that this would
have saved Chris Cornell or anybody else
that did it.
I'm not saying that,
but I mean for some people out there
that aren't feeling good man,
if you just fucking struggled more,
you get over that struggle,
you feel better.
It sounds so simplistic,
but I swear by it I felt shitty myself
and then force myself to workout and
then after I get out of there,
I'm like 100 percent fucking 40 percent
guarantee and you know,
actually I had,
I had,
you know,
I had Tim Ferris come on my podcast and
when he came on he was like,
Hey,
I don't know if I'm the right kind of
guests for your podcast because you
know,
my podcast is like about war and death
and killing and all that stuff.
And so,
you know,
tim's are about being better and stuff
like that.
So it's easy to raise your voice.
Yeah,
that's Tim.
Tim's Tim's podcast is about improving
yourself and mine was about war and
genocide and horrible things and he said
to me,
you know,
hey,
I don't know if,
if I come on the podcast but you know,
maybe I'm not the right type of guest or
whatever,
and I,
and I wrote back to him and I said,
hey man,
you know,
you've been through some dark stuff in
your life because he wrote a blog post
years ago about him being suicidal and
him contemplating and planning commit
suicide.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Did he really?
Yeah,
he went through a full motions.
Got Typical Tim ferriss methodology.
What did he do?
He went to the library and got a whole
bunch of books on killing yourself and
then did the research on how he was
going to do it and planned it all.
And then when was this,
how long ago he was going,
he was like just done with college and
so I mean,
what does that,
what is he 35 or something.
So maybe it's he's 15 years ago and he
was under all this pressure,
you know,
he was an ivy league guy and he was
trying to finish school,
but then it wasn't working out and it
was just problematic.
And so he started saying to myself,
okay,
well how am I getting out of this?
Well,
there's one way to get out of it.
And luckily he didn't do it,
but when he came on,
you know,
that's what we talked about and what he
said,
you know,
as he was making recommendations from
again,
from a guy who's been there was like,
hey,
if,
if you're trapped in your,
in your mind and you're starting to feel
that way,
go do something physical.
Get in your body,
you get out of your mind the same thing
you're saying it when you're feeling
bad,
when you're feeling down,
go out and swing a kettle ball around
and you will feel better.
Yeah.
This is just too much.
For some people especially,
they're just experiencing way too much
pressure and that pressure.
A lot of times it's just a,
an imbalanced and perspective and some
of it's in like a,
I was talking to this,
mom wants,
her daughter does gymnastics with my
daughter and we were talking about um,
kids killing themselves where she used
to live.
She still live in one of the really
wealthy tech areas outside of San
Francisco and a bunch of kids that went
to school with her daughter that were
like 15,
16.
We're jumping off bridges and shit.
Like it was a,
uh,
like an epidemic and they were trying to
figure out what the fuck is going on.
And they're literally calling it
Affluenza.
That these affluent kids and their
families are literally worth a billion
dollars.
You know,
I mean,
everybody's super rich and they're
having this insane pressure.
It like before high school and in high
school to be an Ivy League schools and
to get four point,
oh,
and they're fucking,
they're not having any fun and they're
not experienced in life and they don't
have any hope.
And their parents are all on fucking
pills and they're just killing
themselves.
And as you said,
it really is a piece of perspective
because if you think about,
think about some when you watched one of
your buddies go down the downward
spiral,
maybe it's not the suicide,
but whether it's drug addiction,
a lot of times some female,
the girlfriend,
the ex wife,
we'll just take them on the downward
spiral and there's there,
they can't get out of it.
And if they were to step back,
if they were,
if it was you and your buddy watching
one of your other friends go down this
path,
they go,
oh my God,
I can't believe he's doing that.
That's crazy.
But when you're in that spiral,
people get caught in that and they
can't.
They can't get the perspective of what
it looks like from the outside.
It's hard for people to break momentum
to momentum.
That's good.
Momentum or momentum.
Momentum is bad.
Momentum.
When I get a,
like when I get on a good groove of
working out all the time,
I feel it like after I'm done working
out,
I'm like,
I can't wait to get in there again.
I can't wait to work out again.
That's the good momentum,
but then there's that bad momentum like
you get injured or something like that
and you can't do anything for a couple
of weeks and then to try to get that
kickstart,
that meant motor up the end.
It's hard to get momentum.
I've caught some flack for saying that
there was these big science experiments
or something in the and they said that
willpower dissipates throughout the day
and the more decisions you have to make,
the weaker you get throughout the day,
and I think that's bs.
I agree with what you're saying,
which is when you wake up in the
morning,
you'd get a good workout.
You don't lose willpower,
you actually build it.
You feel better,
you feel stronger,
and then at lunchtime you you're not
saying,
hey,
where's the pizza and where's the
donuts?
No,
at lunchtime you already worked out.
You feel good.
You're like,
hey,
where's the.
Where's the steak?
Where's the protein?
And that carries throughout the day as
opposed to exactly what you're saying,
which is when you sleep in,
you skip your workout.
All of a sudden the donuts are starting
to look pretty good and then the next
thing you know it's pizza and then we
get home at night.
You're just watching TV and that can
continue on for days and then days
turned into weeks and then the next
thing you know you're fat and out of
shape.
Yeah.
And then on top of that,
if they did do that study,
like really I want to know what those
people were eating because that's a big
factor too because there's a lot of
people that are eating shit food and
then by the end of the day your body's
in a crisis,
you're body's just processing all this
bullshit.
Yeah.
And people asked me that too.
They go,
you know,
how much do you sleep?
First of all,
I could ask all the time.
So I go to bed around 11.
I woke up,
wake up around 4:30
every day,
so that's five and a half hours.
Sometimes I sleep more than that.
Sometimes I go to bed at 10,
10,
30,
11.
Sometimes I stay up later.
But when the person says to me,
Oh,
you know,
I can't do that,
I feel horrible.
How can I feel better?
And I.
my first question is like,
well,
what are you eating?
What are you eating?
Because if you're eating cheetos and
chocolate chip cookies for lunch,
there's no way you're going to feel
good.
And I don't care if you slept 12 hours
the night before.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a giant factor.
And if you're eating a big like bullshit
lunch filled with nonsense,
like your body's got to process all that
stuff,
and so the end of the day,
yeah,
you're going to lose your willpower.
So like when 5:00,
6:00
rolls around,
you're going to be tired.
But if you have a healthy lunch and you
know you're,
you're properly fueled.
And then you also have positive people
in your life.
Everyone's motivated by the end of the
day,
you're going to feel good.
Like say if you're,
if you're doing Jujitsu with a bunch of
other people that are doing Jujitsu,
everybody's enjoying it.
You're looking forward to that 6:30
class.
Everybody's fired up.
You get out of work.
You fucking pumped,
man.
What you do when you get out of work,
you're filling up with water and trying
to get some electrolytes in you because
you know you're going to get out there
on the mats and you got to sweat it out
and the thing you've got to do too is
when you get done with work and it was a
grind and you didn't get.
You ate crappy food and whatever
happened happened and you got yelled at
by your boss or whatever,
and they're real easy decision has to be
like,
I'm not going to go try it tonight.
Those the night you got to train because
that is going to kick you back onto
track real quick.
When you get in there and you see your
boys and they're getting ready to tear
you up on the mats and that's going to
get you on track as opposed to going
home and watching TV,
which isn't gonna do anything for you.
Yeah,
and if it's not anything,
whenever the fuck you thing is just go
and do it.
Just force yourself to do it.
And if you feel like shit because you
ate lunch,
then your lunch was filled with
bullshit.
Well then,
hey dummy,
don't eat shitty lunch tomorrow,
tomorrow.
Try a nice salad,
a salad with some salmon,
and see how you feel.
Then you're like,
hey,
I feel way better today at 6:00.
Duh.
Yeah.
Now your decision making will be better.
Like people don't understand how
significant it is.
Like all these little decisions,
they,
those are the.
That's the path for the rest of your
existence on earth.
And if you decide to go to fucking
cheetos,
chocolate chip cookie route,
you're.
If you're just making a shit path,
you're carving your fucking path through
broken rocks and glass.
And it's not the way to go.
There's no doubt that the,
the life change decision isn't one big
decision that you make.
It's all these little tiny decisions.
It's,
you know,
having a salad instead of cheetos.
That's,
that's,
that's what it is on a daily basis.
And if you think about that and then you
just make the right decision on those
little things,
that's where,
that's where the change is reaching your
refrigerator.
You see the cocacola right next to the
water,
just like to grab that water,
just do it and no,
you don't want to put.
Just do it and you'd be like,
I fucking did it.
I grabbed the water.
Listen,
water doesn't taste good compared to
coca cola.
If your body is craving that heroin of
Coca Cola,
but the reality is if you were out in
the desert and you saw a cold bottle of
water,
you wouldn't be so excited for that
water blood.
Oh,
it would be the most delicious thing
ever.
When you're at a restaurant,
you're like,
oh,
you're going to eliminate,
you don't want a soda.
I,
I want some.
Some mouth pleasure,
and if you've ever been truly thirsty
before,
like in the desert and you haven't had
water or you didn't bring enough water
and you're really thirsty,
you see coke isn't even appealing at
that nice nasty you can get to fill.
It really is.
You get in that mode where you've been
truly thirsty,
which I've been before.
You know,
just not like I was going to die,
but I've been close to getting some sort
of a heat stroke scenario happening and,
and then got to extreme pump the water,
drink the water,
and that's the most beautiful thing in
the world.
And you don't have water and you get it.
I bet more so even if you get it from a
stream and then pumping it through a
filter and you know,
just getting it right out of the earth.
So good.
Oh,
so what?
You're supposed to have folks where I
think people are supposed to struggle.
I think there's,
there's a part of us that longs for the
old times when we were just some sort of
primitive monkey people running away
from animals.
So there's that.
That's still in our DNA.
There is no doubt that you have an
instinct.
I mean that's why we play sports,
right?
You got to play sports because you want
to compete with people and,
and look at the rise of the UFC.
Why is that?
Because that's the most primal sport you
can possibly come up with is I'm going
to fight you.
That's what we're going to do in a cage.
So why is that so popular?
We still have that instinct that we want
to.
We want to fight and we want to
struggle.
We want to survive.
You know,
Dana White and I have talked about this
so many times that it transcends every
language.
Like cricket is so giant in England,
right?
And then India,
try putting that shit on TV in America
will be like,
good pitch.
Get that fucking stupid paddle game on
TV.
What the fuck are you doing?
We don't even know what's going on.
Or conversely,
baseball,
you played baseball to some country that
doesn't accept baseball.
They're like,
what is this nonsense?
It's takes forever.
Knowing the real sport of MMA like is
not.
I mean it is unquestionably,
it's a sport and there are rules,
but it transcends.
You know what's happening.
You might not understand the ground that
much when,
when submissions,
but when you see a guy turning red
because the other guys behind him
choking the fucking life out of them,
you get it.
You see what's happening.
You understand it.
That's another cool thing.
If you ever,
you ever teach kids Jujitsu?
Yeah.
It's so awesome to say no,
you want to put this guy down and that's
all you need to say that they go,
okay.
And then you give them a little,
little,
little tastes of information.
Like if you grabbed their legs and push
them,
they'll fall down and that's all you
need to tell them.
And then there'll be basically doing
double leg take downs instinctively.
And it's savage.
It's beautiful.
It is beautiful.
But you can't do that with,
you know,
with a regular sport like baseball.
Okay.
What you're going to do is you're going
to have this guy throw the ball to three
times every time you swing up to Mrs.
so that goes to him and he was,
how's that work?
No.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
there's something feels good about like
choking somebody,
you know,
it's just,
there's something about it,
like even if you're not hurting him,
I mean it just feels good is it feels
like you're supposed to do it.
Maybe it's just you and I,
you know,
I think anybody,
I think anybody that tries it and gets
that,
that's why that's why did you choose
getting so popular because you take a
random person on the street,
Male,
female,
10 years old,
20 years old,
40 years old,
you put them on and you say,
okay,
when you get them this other person in
this position right here and you get
their arm around,
you get your arm around their neck,
you can kill them or you can accept that
you can accept their tap and you can
have mercy on them.
That's a powerful feeling.
It is.
We know what other things that's
powerful about it is the two guys can be
friends and practice killing each other
and not even hurt each other like,
like I'm sure you,
you,
you've recognized that.
Like I feel better working out with
black belts.
I feel safer for sure.
Training with guys that are like super
high level than I do with even guys that
are like an athletic white belt.
It might spazz out and accidentally
headbutted me.
Yeah,
and I mean I could ask that question all
the time too,
is uh,
people say,
Hey,
am I too old to start your Juto I'm 52
years old,
I'm 49 years old and what I tell them
is,
you're not too old,
you're definitely not too old,
but you need to be smart and one of the
smartest you need to make is choosing
your training partners and you don't
want to train.
If you're a 52 year old guy that's never
trained before and you're a white belt
and you're going to get on the mat,
the person you don't want to train with
is the other white belt that's 22 years
old that's on steroids,
that's going to go psycho and he's going
to,
he just,
he just doesn't know how to control his
body.
Whereas the black belt,
the black belt,
the percentage chance of you being hurt
by a black belt if you're a white belt,
that's just,
you know,
trying is nearly zero,
nearly zero,
zero
if it's a legit blackbelt yeah,
yeah.
I teach my kids class sometimes my kid
takes a mixed martial arts class and the
instructor asked me to come in and
demonstrate one particular type of move
the other day and so I started,
I demonstrated it and we were talking
about some different positions that are
important for kids to recognize like how
to make sure you don't get like kids
were given up their back where they were
trying to pass guard.
They were trying to pass guard and they
were pushing down and I'm like,
you never want to turn your shoulder
like that because I had explained to
them the arm drag.
So I'm explaining to these kids to arm
drag and you see the little brain
spinning man and you see them practicing
on each other and they're laughing and
they're girls,
you know.
So you're watching these eight year old
girls having the best time,
like choking each other and everything
and going through these motions.
And to me,
I mean I think it's fucking awesome man.
These kids do it all the time.
No one's getting hurt.
They're having a great time with each
other and it's just this primal release
like let's get all that shit out of
there and then you can
be civil.
Yeah,
well even if there's no Jujitsu
instruction involved and there's no mats
around and you take two kids and you put
them in the yard,
eventually they're going to start
wrestling with each other.
Boys.
Yeah,
boys for sure.
Yes,
for sure.
I was at a party
once with my kids and these two boys
started going at it and it neither one
of them at any training you could tell,
but it's just natural.
Like they,
they're getting their hips low and that
trying to push each other and trying to
figure it out and neither one of them
knew what to do.
Kind of wanted to go up and start
coaching them,
but they're just playing in the grass.
I didn't want.
You know,
it's like,
it's,
it's fascinating to see just natural
human instincts.
Yeah.
And that's the other thing I've noticed
in teaching kids Jujitsu is the kids
that are a little bit more cerebral,
your,
the parents will think,
well,
you know,
my son,
he's,
he's kind of a nerd.
He's kind of a smart kid.
I don't know if he's going to like this,
but the opposite is actually true very
often where the kid that's cerebral,
he'll recognize as soon as you show them
three things,
like you said,
his wheels are turning.
He's going to wait a second.
This is,
this is a skill I can learn and if I
know this that and the other guy doesn't
know this,
I'll be able to beat him.
And so cerebral kids often get into it
even more than,
than some kid.
That's just kind of a natural bruiser Oh
yeah,
that means 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu is
filled with nerds.
They're all nerds,
they're assassin nerds.
It's really kind of interesting.
It is.
And,
and you're,
you're,
you're not being facetious when you use
the word assassin nerds,
because you know,
this is,
you know,
if you go back before you knew Jujitsu
before I knew you did before I knew
Jujitsu and you know,
all was a big navy shield,
200 pounds,
one of those kids,
that's 145 pounds would absolutely have
destroyed me if we've got new fight,
boom,
take my back,
put me to sleep,
you know what I mean?
I,
I might,
you know,
put up an okay fight and hit him one
time in the side of the head and then
he's in on my back and put me to sleep.
That's the reality.
Nerd assassins coming at you strong.
Well,
it is.
It's a complex game of kinetic chest.
I mean,
it's more complex than chess because you
know,
in chess you've got these different
pieces and they're restricted in their
movements.
Jujitsu's not restricted in its
movement.
And every transition has so many
different possibilities and so many
different setups are so many different
times.
You get led one way and then just to get
you to defend so that they can establish
the second position and they get you to
defend that so they can establish a
third position.
Yeah,
and that part of it is is what I think
really for me,
transferred from Jujitsu to not only to
the battlefield but to life as well
because the big thing in Jujitsu from my
perspective is that you don't go
strength against strength.
Right?
If I'm,
if I'm trying to choke you,
I don't try and choke you overtly.
I don't just grab your neck.
No,
I work on your arm and I put pressure
over here and I pass your guard and then
I eventually,
while you're thinking about something
else,
boom,
that's when I grabbed your neck or
that's when I grabbed her arm and that's
what I think on the battlefield.
You know,
you can't,
you just don't attack hardened to
positions of the enemy and in life,
you know,
if you're trying to be a leader,
you're trying to step up and lead
somebody.
If you don't just come down and bark
orders at people because that's not as
effective as maneuvering and adjusting
your position and getting in a better
position and then getting that person to
give you what you want instead of trying
to take it from them.
Yeah.
That's a really important lesson for
parenthood.
Like you can't just tell kids what to
do.
Just do it because I told you to do it.
They're like,
fuck you.
I'm going to be a hooker and that
applies not only to kids at your hundred
percent applies to kids,
but it applies to adults as well and
that is people need to understand why
they're doing what they're doing and you
know,
if I want you to go take down some
building and capture some bad guy,
I don't go,
hey,
hey joe,
I want you to go take down this
building.
Once you capture the bad guy,
these are the guys I want you to take
with you.
Here's the route I want you to take in.
Here's the methodology I want you to use
for the clearance because then when I
send you to go do that mission,
it's not your mission,
it's my mission.
I came up with the plan.
You didn't,
so you might be.
You might have thought there was a
better way to do it or you might have
had a different idea of how to get it
done,
and now when you go out there and you
meet some kind of resistance,
whether it's an obstacle you didn't
expect or whether it's some scenario
that you didn't foresee,
instead of you trying to overcome it,
you just blame me.
He just looked at Jocko,
came up with a stupid plan,
and here we are.
It's failing.
Forget it.
We're going back.
We're not going to carry out the
mission.
Whereas if I said,
hey joe,
here's what I want you to do,
go figure out the best way to do it and
now you come up with a plan and now you
make up all the methodology of how
you're going to get it done and you
decide who you're going to take with
you.
Now it's your plan.
You own that plant and when you go out
in the field and you meet a little
resistance,
guess what you do?
You say,
I'm going to find a way around it.
I'm going to overcome
this.
I'm going to overcome that obstacle and
to make it happen,
and that's another piece of leadership
and it's the exact same thing with kids.
If you tell your kid,
you know you will get good grades in
school,
that means nothing to them,
but if you explain to them,
Hey,
I would love for you to get good grades
and here's why.
It's going to open opportunities for you
in the future.
It's going to allow you to be able to
outsmart people because you can have
more knowledge than them and then you're
gonna be able to end up making more
money,
which is actually gonna give you more
freedom in the long run.
Instead of doing a job that you don't
want to do.
You explain all those things to a kid is
going to be a lot more successful than
just do what I told you.
Get good grades because I said so.
Now,
when you do these conferences where when
you speak it at a businesses and they
bring you in to sort of have these
leadership meeting,
what,
what would you call them?
Yeah,
their leadership seminars,
seminars.
Now when you have these seminars or
these,
uh,
some of the principles that you
discussed when you talk about.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Because that's another,
another big piece of this is that all
just ideas about interacting with human
beings.
They just don't change.
Like there's a little variance,
but whether you're dealing with kids or
whether you're dealing with adults and
whether you're dealing with business
people,
whether you're dealing with soldiers on
the battlefield,
the leadership principles,
they don't change and therefore you can,
whether you're trying to get people to
go out and capture and kill a bad guy or
whether you're trying to get them to
build some product and sell it,
the principal's leadership don't change.
You're still trying to get a bunch of
totally independent people.
Right?
And that's one of the myths we have to
overcome a lot because everyone thinks,
oh,
in the military have just like a robot.
And that's just not true.
Everybody in the military is free.
There are people,
they're people,
they're free thinking people and they're
gonna come up with own ideas they're
gonna have with their own agendas and
they're going to think of ways to do
things that they think are better than
yours.
So you're gonna have all these
independent free thinkers and you got to
get them onboard with the same plan to
you to go out and execute.
And so it doesn't matter if you're on
the battlefield or in business.
That's what.
That's what you're trying to get done.
And the leadership principles don't
change that.
To me,
that's as a person who's never been in
the military.
That's one of the fascinating aspects of
how it works is like how,
how do you get all these different
people to follow through on a plan and
who are the leaders and why did the
leaders have the right ideas and who
educates them as to how the have the
right idea to having the right ideas.
Like I know that a lot of people are
excited about where the military is
right now.
Like Tim Kennedy re enlisted and he the
lesson.
Yeah,
he resisted because he believes that the
military has support now and look,
Tim Kennedy's believes he was put on
this earth to kill bad guys and that's
what he wants to do.
I think I agree with Tim Kennedy.
I think I agree with them too,
for sure.
Obviously he enjoys it.
He's not fucking around me.
He went back in,
he put his money where his mouth is and
in his eyes that this is,
you know,
this is the way that it should have
been,
that you should give the military the
chance to do their job.
That's their idea.
And then other people believe that there
should be much more civilian oversight
and they should be much more,
much more checks and balances before
things get done.
This is a,
this
is a big debate that's going on today.
Well,
I think there's two different things
that you just talked about.
That is what the military gets told to
do and how they do it.
And those are two different things.
And I,
I think that yes,
you absolutely,
the civilians should control and do
control the military by the way they do
control.
The civilians are undercut or the
military is under controlled civilians
and yet once you say,
okay,
this is what we want to have happen,
you need to let the military
professionals figure out how they're
going to go and make it happen.
Yeah,
that's,
that's where it gets tricky,
right?
Because if you're in like one of the
things that was explained to me by a
friend who's navy seal,
he was saying that when something needs
to get done and you have all these
people that are telling you how you can
do it,
how you can't do it,
that people that are not in experiencing
combat and don't understand what,
what could or could not go sideways like
to put more problems in place or to put
more checks and balances in place,
you're actually going to put these
people in
danger that that is true.
You should.
Like I said,
if you let the civilians decide what it
is that needs to be accomplished and
then the military leaders decide how
they're going to go ahead and make that
happen and I mean it goes back to,
goes back to Vietnam,
you know,
there was too much civilian oversight of
what was happening in Vietnam and the
military leaders were.
They didn't really have the,
the wherewithal,
not even the wherewithal.
They didn't have the free reign to go
out and try and make things happen the
way they want to do and it ended up in a
big quagmire.
Well,
Vietnam seems like to me,
from an outsider to be one of the most
fucked up wars ever,
absolutely.
It didn't totally make sense that it was
happening and then now we know that the
Gulf,
the Gulf of Tonkin was very likely a
false flag and that there was some sort
of motivation to get there in the first
place and then you're dealing with
guerrilla warfare for the first time
ever in US history.
Like they didn't exactly know how to
handle this.
No,
we didn't and we didn't adapt very well.
To what was happening on the ground,
which is always going to be problematic
if you have closed minded people in the
military,
if people are closed mind that you're
not going to be able to move forward
against,
uh,
when,
when the battlefield changes and the
battlefield changes all the time.
I mean,
you can look at Iraq,
Iraq,
the battlefield change drastically from
this big conventional force that we went
up there to fight against Saddam's big
army.
Well,
once that fell apart,
then what happened?
Now all of a sudden we were facing
gorillas again and an insurgency and it
took us several years to change our
strategy from.
We didn't even know what to do.
We're like,
oh my God,
you know,
what do we do?
There's all these people running around.
What do we do with these all these
people running around and how do we get
these people under control and,
and the civilians want us here.
And,
and yet,
if we don't do the right thing now the
civilians don't want us here.
What do we need to do?
So it took us some time to adjust our
strategy in Iraq.
And Luckily we had some good leaders
that that went ahead and made those
changes.
Isn't it also that when when you're in
war and the strategy and not the
strategy,
but the is very clear,
like if you fight against Hitler's army
in World War Two,
but this is very
clear that you're dealing with an evil
force.
Whereas in Vietnam it's like,
wait a minute,
why are we here?
Like what's going on?
Communism.
What's happening?
Extremely,
extremely challenging,
no doubt.
And that that is why I've talked about
this before.
If,
if America or any nation is going to go
to war,
you have to decide that this is the most
important thing in the world.
You have to end the wills that I talk
about,
that you have to have to execute this
war.
You gotta have you gotTa have the will
to kill people.
And again,
I say this all the time,
no one wants to hear it because it's
ugly and horrible,
but when you say you're gonna kill
people in war,
you're not just going to be able to
perfectly killed just the bad guys.
Civilians are going to die.
It is a nightmare.
Kids,
women.
It's horrible.
It's awful,
and if you think,
oh,
I'm going to go to war and we're just
going to kill the bad guys,
it's not gonna happen in war is too
complex.
It's just not going to be.
It'd be saying like,
Hey,
I'm going to go and fight in the UFC and
I'm not going to get hit.
It's not going to happen.
You're going to get hit,
you're going to get bruised up,
you're going to get dinged,
and it's the same thing in war.
So you have to have the will to kill
people.
Of course it's easy to have the will to
kill the bad guys,
but then you have to accept the fact
that some innocent people are going to
die and that is going to be awful.
And then on the other side of the coin
is of course,
if you're going to send people to war,
people,
Americans are going to die and there's
nothing you can do about it.
You have to accept that fact and you
know,
that's why Vietnam was just the ultimate
tragedy and in many respects,
because we were killing a lot of
civilians.
We were losing a lot of Americans,
but we weren't progressing the way we
needed to.
It was a nightmare.
I agree with you 100 percent.
What do you think about transparency?
Like when the Bush administration
wouldn't let them take photographs of
coffins and send them home like a lot of
people were really upset because there's
a lot of people that felt like,
look,
America should know that there's a cost
to this and they should know that
there's consequences to these actions,
and they were saying that these
consequences and knowing about these
consequences could lesson morale,
could lessen support back at home when
they really need it,
and the people didn't really need to
know this is what they need to know is
we're on the right track and we're doing
well.
That's a tough one.
And whether it's the right decision to
keep the Americans and their beautiful
bubble that they live in and let them
know that this war is happening,
but you don't have to see the brave
Americans coming home that are
sacrificed their lives.
And interestingly,
if you remember,
I think it was Tara,
what the battle of when World War II and
for the first time,
so we were,
we needed money to run world war two,
a lot of money,
war bonds and all that,
and we were kind of falling behind and
we needed some money.
And one of the first times that they
released a lot of pictures of American
dead Americans was,
I think it was the battle of Tarawa.
And there was all these Americans
washing up on the beach.
I mean marines that had drowned,
got shot.
And it was awful.
But they did it for a reason.
They did it to show like,
hey,
this is real.
This is happening.
We need to put pitch in.
We need money,
we need to save,
save,
meet,
save a oil,
don't use your cars.
We all need to get in for the big win,
right?
And that's the opposite of what we're
talking about when they're saying,
hey,
you're not allowed to take pictures of,
of native Americans that are being
killed.
And you know,
I,
I think there should be some level of
transparency there when you should.
America should see what is happening,
what is the cost?
Because it's real easy for Americans to,
to sit there and allow these young kids
to go overseas and fight and die or be
wounded,
gravely wounded,
and just to shut those.
Just ignore them because I'm,
I don't care because I'm over here in
the mall.
No,
maybe we should,
uh,
maybe we should not only,
you know,
maybe we should not only show pictures
of the coffins that are coming back,
but maybe we should explore and show the
lives that those men sacrificed and who
they were and what they did and what
their families are like and their wife
and kids and mom and dad that they left
behind,
that they gave up.
And why did they give it up?
Because they believed in freedom.
And so now we just going to say,
oh,
that's not happening.
No,
it's happening.
And you need to,
you need to know it.
It is kind of strange,
right?
When you think about how little access
to information people really had back in
world war two,
they were counting on the news and they
were counting on newspapers and now
today we have massive,
massive access to information
instantaneously.
But yet you get less of it when it comes
to that.
Yeah.
And,
and in some ways you get more of it.
I mean obviously when there's an
incident that happens overseas,
you can find out about it on twitter as
fast as you can find out about it
through,
you know,
waiting for a real nice horse to come up
with it.
But you don't get anything that's like
specifically distributed by the US
government to let you know the
consequences of war and say,
Hey folks,
we need your support.
This is what's really going down.
These are American citizens and this is
what's happening to them over there.
Yeah.
And then the same thing could be said
for,
hey,
sometimes civilians are going to get
killed and what do we do?
What do we do?
Then do we brush that under the rug and
we just show the Americans getting
killed?
Or do you universally show what's
happening?
What war is men wore is jacked up.
I'm here to tell you,
war is not glorious.
It is not fun.
And it is,
it is a horrible,
horrible event.
And so yeah,
I think you should expose it and I think
you should expose it at a,
at a high level so that people
understand what we're getting into.
And,
and as horrible as war is,
there's many times throughout history
where war is the absolute in my mind,
in my opinion,
the right thing to do and we don't have
a choice and we need to do something
when,
when horrible things are happening.
And,
and you know,
I think that's,
you know,
on my podcast I talk about like the,
like I said,
I talk about war and death and horrible
genocide and,
and that's one of the reasons why I
think it's gotten a lot of traction is
because I'm talking about things that
are otherwise being ignored.
And I think people do want to know.
I think people do want to understand war
to deeper level,
so that way when they hear a politician
to up there saying,
hey,
we should go to war,
they can at least save themselves.
I know what I know what he's talking
about.
And he's not just talking about,
hey,
we're going to wave the flag.
We're going gonna send some soldiers
over there and they're kick ass.
They're going to come home and we're
gonna high five.
That's not what war is.
And let's not ever forget that.
War is a man and another man on a
battlefield surrounded by people,
civilians,
and they're trying to kill each other
and it's a blood bath and we shouldn't
forget that.
And is it necessary?
Sometimes?
It absolutely is.
It absolutely is necessary sometimes,
but we better way our our minds heavily
before we make that decision to go and
execute.
Now,
when you think about the evolution of
human beings,
so you think about how much safer it is
today versus how it was thousands of
years ago.
Do you ever foresee a time where war
won't exist?
I don't know.
You know,
people joke with me a lot about the
robot wars and and robots being able to
accomplish wars.
I actually believed that thing will
come.
I mean we've got drones right now that
that are very capable and pretty soon
we'll have land warfare robots that will
be able to go in and clear buildings and
make things happen and then we'll the
enemy then have robots that will fight
our robots at some point.
Yeah,
and then at some point will that elevate
to a point where we're not dealing with
physical robots anymore,
but just the software behind the robots
and now it's just a big sort of cyber
warfare that is,
that seems conceivable to me now joe,
don't mistake me for some kind of like a
Sam Harris intellectual over here or
that I'm going to sit here and explain
to you what the future of warfare from a
technical perspective,
but from my,
from my rudimentary thought process,
could it not elevate to a point where we
have robots fighting robots and then
that eventually escalates to a point
where it's some kind of cyber warfare
with.
It's not physical,
but it's just information based and that
does make sense to me that that could
happen.
Yeah,
it makes sense to me too.
Especially when you see those Boston
dynamic robots.
Have you seen those are all things.
You kick them over,
they bounced back up.
They run up hills.
They can run like 60 miles an hour.
The freaks.
I mean it's really what they're doing
now is just.
I mean,
who knows where they're going to be 10
years from now,
I mean they're going to be solar powered
the live out there with no food.
Yeah,
it'll be awesome.
And then.
And then then where we go with those
robots,
fight people for awhile.
Probably people that don't know any
people that don't.
People that don't have good robots yet
and that's not going to be fun for the
people without robots.
Right.
And we'll see where it goes from there.
I mean,
I think that's just a surrender
scenario,
right?
If you got a,
a,
a.
If let's say America has these robots
that can just come in with ruthless
precision and take out bad guys and you
know you're going to be at their mercy.
There's a fucking science fiction be
right.
Like China develops robots that take
over New York City.
You look at this guy.
I'm thinking as one of these buses,
robots.
It's just,
it's so weird,
man.
To see them moving around.
Yeah,
and what's interesting,
I've seen some other ones
like you don't need them.
They put all this effort into making it
actually walk instead of have,
you know,
wheels or tracks or whatever.
The wheels or tracks with a little pods
that could get over things would be they
want this to look like for a person.
For some reason a human shape is not
necessarily the most effective structure
for fighting.
It's not even real for us.
Right.
Yeah.
Apparently that's one of the reason why
our backs are so fucked up.
You know,
he can't even talk us into standing up
straight,
uh,
can pick up 10 pounds.
Okay.
That's a big deal.
I'm better than that.
Yeah.
Fuck this robot someday though.
Well,
it's just,
we like things that look like us for,
for whatever reason.
You know,
we liked the idea that this thing is
going to look like us,
but yeah,
I agree with you.
It doesn't need to and it should
probably not the best.
And the real,
the real combat robots probably won't
look like they won't be bipedal.
Yeah.
They won't be bipedal.
They'll probably have a little treads or
something and just haul ass at 60 miles
an hour with the machine guns.
They'll have many legs,
like a.
well,
what was that one that was like a
cheetah.
There's some,
some crazy one.
It's like a Cheetah and it runs at some
fucking ridiculous speed and it's
terrifying.
They had one that was on a treadmill.
Is this the Cheetah one again?
It's obviously not the best galloping.
It's not the best structure because you
have to make this thing up and run.
Whereas with wheels on it or treads or
something.
Like a tank.
A tank.
Yeah.
But I wonder like for getting over logs
and stuff like that,
if there's any sort of benefit,
they also have those ones that leap up
in the air and they can go over there,
go over the top of walls and shit.
Yeah,
that's what you need is some kind of
legs that can pop out if they need to.
Yeah.
Maybe we should just design this thing
and take a look.
Here you go.
Here's one of the wheels.
Yeah,
so you guys got get the best of both.
Yeah.
It's fucking terrifying.
That was got front legs and back wheels.
Yeah.
They're not fucking playing games and
didn't google buy them in that Google
skynet?
That's what we should be careful of.
Google is powerful.
God Damn.
Their big announcement they made this
week about their google io at assistant
ai stuff is pretty crazy too.
I don't know a bunch of information so I
can't tell you.
Just look it up because we're getting
scared.
This is like the Google theory type
thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
This is for the new pixel phone.
Yup.
What does it was launched an extra
announcements on top of that to what's
supposed to be significant.
Whoa.
Do you see that thing?
Jump over a fucking look at this?
Yeah.
See,
that's the thing.
You Go.
Fuck that thing.
See,
without even knowing it,
I was saying wheels is perfect.
You go back,
rewind that a little bit.
Watch it.
Go over the wall.
He jumps over a wall.
We'll a little bit before that.
Yeah.
Watch this.
Watch with this fucking thing.
Can do man.
After it does this,
it goes down these stairs and then it
gets to.
I mean,
it gets to this wall like a hurdle and
it fucking bounces over this hurdle.
Like it's nothing.
There's snow,
doesn't matter.
Grass doesn't matter.
Doesn't break one of those stupid
wheels.
The problem is,
what are those wheels made out?
You shoot one of those wheels,
I think fuck,
but look at it.
Bounces right over that.
No problem.
Tucks its legs.
It looks terrifying and they put it
covered in like some creepy fucking fake
skin.
Like an alien,
you know?
Yeah.
And then you'd put sensors on it,
a thermal sensors and night vision
sensors and you wouldn't be able to get
away from it.
Yeah.
You know,
what's something you down and kill you.
I mean just think about that technology
and then add that tesla technology for
self driving cars and knows where all
the cars are and everything.
We're just,
we're just a few years away from
something very,
very bizarre.
Again,
I kind of look forward to it.
Bring on the robots,
all of the flight or I'll go down to a
blaze of glory.
Yeah.
That's ripping out battery chords and
trying to take their lives.
Yeah.
Arnold Schwarzenegger in Terminator,
it's funny because when the Google
assistant can see and understand the
world around you,
they built that like google the Google
Lens thing that used to be existing and
they took it away.
It's kind of just built that thing you
tried,
you know,
you mean Google Glass Lens is that thing
that translates the world,
that translates languages?
They did.
They just kind of put all that data into
this and so now it's on that phone and
everyone will have it that has the new
pixel.
And so what does it do?
It's doing a bunch.
As far as I know right now it's a bunch
of ai information.
So it's looking at barcodes and qr codes
all over the place and it's,
you don't even have to have a really
high,
excuse me,
a good version of it.
You can do it from far away and they can
read it.
It can be really low.
A pixilated not saying they're right
where I'm losing the word.
Um,
resolution,
low resolution.
You can have a low resolution.
It can pick it up from faraway to off
the TV.
So that's cool.
This gas was bark.
Why?
Why do you need to read barcodes?
Yeah.
Well,
I know one thing,
it's the new pixel supposed to do,
like say if you have like this Stevia
and you went,
oh,
I want to get this,
you know,
it's got a little barcode.
You put your phone up to it,
show you a link on Amazon and you can
one click it just like.
Right.
So that's one good thing that it does
for the barcodes,
but you know,
it can compare prices in stores.
It's saying automatically whether it's
using Amazon and they'll block that
be.
So basically we're moving into the
ultimate age of consumerism.
It's just a step up in instantaneous,
instantaneous purchasing.
But like as far as like reading the
world around you,
what else is it doing?
Uh,
I mean,
I think you'd have to hold it up to see
it.
So right here it says you can aim it at
a flower and it will,
and it will identify the species.
You can pull up a band's music or videos
by pointing the lens at a concert
poster.
Whoa.
So like right now there's something that
popped up Annapolis Fund recently that
people don't really know because it's
hard to see.
Like if I type in your name,
joe gets underlined,
if you click that,
a whole bunch of information pops up and
leads to like all of your things on
apple music.
It leads to your webpage.
It's like a little serious assistant
thing.
But it's,
it hasn't been advertised and it's not
really doesn't work for every person
name.
Like it might not work for Jocko willink
but it will work for Joe Rogan and it
might in the future if they update it or
I don't know who needs to update it.
But that's Kinda cool too.
This is an updated version of that I
believe,
just to bring this conversation back to
where we were the further we go in this
direction of technology being in every
part of our lives,
the further away we get from having to
struggle with things and the bigger hole
there's going to be in the hole that you
sense and I sense which is if you're not
struggling,
if you're not working you for not
fighting for something that's just going
to go further and further into the past
and further and further down and people
are going to have that hole to fill up
somehow.
Yeah.
The physical body needs.
It has requirements.
That is stress requirements and if I
always did the way I talk about it's
like a battery
and like almost like not a conventional
better the way we think of as,
but almost like a storage vessel for
energy and then if you don't do anything
with that energy,
it's sort of oozes over the side and
fucking battery acid crust.
The outside of it like it gets all
fucked up,
but if you just keep pumping out energy,
you keep doing something.
It maintained some sort of homeostasis
and maintain some sort of a balance
point.
It had maintained some sort of a,
um,
a operational happiness like w where the
body's not fighting against itself
because I think that a lot of people's
bodies are just fighting against them
and a lot of like the way that decisions
that are making,
it's a big of a,
a big part of it is it's just not taking
care of their meat vehicles.
So there's getting all this confusing
messages from the flesh.
Yeah,
I mean we see that everyday when you
walk around America and you see people
that are just,
you wonder how much longer they're going
to be able to survive.
And what happens if they,
if there's a fire and they have to run,
they're not going to make it around the
corner to go to Disneyland.
Everybody's on a scooter.
It's weird.
It's so weird.
And I have a friend that works at
Disneyland and he was telling me like,
he started working there 10 years ago.
It was rare to see someone on a scooter
and now they're all on scooters and then
not on scooters because they got a
broken leg or they're old.
They're on scooters because they've
eaten themselves into this unmanageable
shape.
Well,
again,
even five years ago,
if you wanted to eat yourself into
miserable shape,
you had to walk to the grocery store to
do that,
which was at least some form of movement
and now you just one click on Amazon and
you got the the cheetos in ultra large
size showing up at your front door.
Two hours and they're gonna come in at
drone soon.
Yeah,
and by the way,
you can just be like cheetos and then
it'll.
It'll put you up.
The other things that you will probably
want to.
You want you to what?
You probably want two liters of coke and
you probably want some marshmallows to
go with that and there you go.
Two hours.
It's there.
You're just killing yourself.
What the fuck man?
Like when is this gonna end?
I wonder when they're going to be able
to figure out a way to compensate for
all the shit.
Just some sort of a,
a pill that figures out,
or even crisper I was,
I was listening to this radio lab
podcast where they're updating crispr.
Where do you know what Crispr
is?
No,
it's a new tool that they have that
they're using to modify genes and they,
uh,
they've only figured it out over the
last few years and apparently they've
already started doing work on non-viable
fetuses in China with this.
That's what they say.
Who knows whether they want by the time
they say that,
my thought is the guy telling you is
probably some fucking fake person by
then.
By the time it actually gets to the
news,
who knows what kind of crazy
advancements they're making,
you know,
behind the Iron Curtain.
Or is there an iron curtain anymore?
Well,
there's China and there's definitely
some things going on in China for sure
they're doing some dark shit with people
in this goddamn technology,
but they think that they're not only
going to be able to use this gene
editing tool,
but they're going to be able to implant
this gene editing tool into our genetics
so that your own genes start doing the
work of Crispr for you,
so things like they're.
They think that it's going to take the
place of antibiotics,
they think it's going to be able to edit
out things like Alzheimer's,
like whatever the gene is for
Alzheimer's.
They'll be able to edit that out so
Alzheimer's will no longer exist.
It's going to be really,
really strange because people are going
to have to make decisions.
Yeah,
and I think this stuff is going to come
quickly once it like.
Once we turn the corner and it seems
like it's going to come fast.
Oh,
it's going to come real fast.
There's going to be some weird mutations
that happen in there too.
Yeah.
There's going to be people that look
like the hulk.
There's going to be going to be people
that have won it in two heads and is
going to be all jacked up and they're
going to.
What do we knew?
Those people,
the ones that didn't like you got that.
It didn't work,
right?
Tiawana crispr job was Chris Hill is.
No,
it's some sort of a gene editing tool.
I don't know the actual mechanism behind
it.
I don't understand it.
I've only listened to people talk about
it and read things on it and then how
far away is immortality from that
because I want you to eliminate all
these different diseases.
Yeah.
I think like 100 years and I always
thought if you could just clone your
body and then you let your body grow to
be 20 years old,
then you just take your brain out,
put it inside that new body,
then you're good to go because I think
it's going to be even creepier than
that.
I think they're gonna be able to turn
back the clock because I think that when
you think about like cellular aging,
like,
well,
what is it?
Your body's not reproduce every cell in
your body except for your neurons
reproduces like somewhere between every
three to seven years or something like
that.
Right?
Your neurons are the only things that
you keep for the,
for the whole life.
And so what they're thinking is that
like as time goes on and your,
you know,
your cells reproduce shittier and
Shittier,
your telomeres shrink.
It doesn't do what?
Well,
they'll be able to flip that around so
that as time goes on,
you'll be like Benjamin buttons.
You'll start getting younger and
younger,
which will be really weird if they fuck
it up and you start turning into a baby,
you know,
you're like some 50 year old.
Then all of a sudden you're like,
dude,
I'm 12 again.
Like this is not good.
Next year I'm going to be 11.
You know,
like if it goes backwards and that
direction,
if they can literally halt it,
like if they can take you.
And then like say if you're a 40 year
woman and
they put you on a 20 year program and
they're like,
well in 20 years instead of being 60,
you're going to be 20 and this is how
it's going to work.
Next year you're going to be 39 next.
That's totally conceivable.
Totally 100 percent conceivable
possible.
And likely,
yeah.
Then then that a mortality thing isn't
that far away.
Then the only thing that's gonna fuck
you up as accidents and murder and shit
like that.
And Mr Rhodes is life become more
precious than.
Because now you're thinking,
Hey,
I don't want to go skydiving because I
could actually live for thousands of
years if I don't screw this up.
I think more likely you're going to see
a lot more par corp and those assholes
that are doing back flips off the Grand
Canyon.
Like that kind of shit.
You're going to see more,
more,
more people that are wanting to feel
alive by taking crazy risks.
Those Russian dudes though.
Well,
I had James Kingston on the podcast.
He's that crazy asshole from England.
Great Kid.
But he's.
He's does back flips on the top of
fucking buildings and Dubai and shit.
Like,
what are you doing,
man?
Yeah.
You posted one of those the other day.
He said something like,
you know,
I don't know how you wrote it,
but you said something like my
sentiments exactly that is jacked up.
It was one just a couple of days ago.
These guys released it.
They were on the Golden Gate Bridge.
I didn't even watch it.
Do you see Jamie?
I wouldn't even watch it though,
like daredevils were on the Golden Gate
Bridge,
but you see them on the very top of the
golden gate bridge doing some silly shit
hanging off the edge.
Like I did some dumb stuff when I was
younger.
I did some rock climbing without ropes.
Not not any Alex honnold stuff,
but you know where I would definitely
get injured if I fell.
That was just being young and stupid.
I remember one time we were.
I was on a ship out in the middle of the
navy ship out in the middle of the ocean
somewhere.
I was in a seal platoon somewhere and me
and one of my buddies,
we were doing pull ups off the side of
the ship at night on a little cable.
Oh Jesus.
That cable breaks or if we slip off and
fall,
you're 100 percent going to die.
But we were doing it anyways because we
were just young and stupid.
Wow.
Want to feel that juice?
The juice prewar you know,
there's no war going on.
How do we prove to our buddies that we
are brave and bad ass or you do stupid
stuff,
dumb stuff hanging off the side of a
ship on a cable.
What does that rush like?
It's got to be a crazy rush.
Right?
And knowing that you can't let go.
It's just dumb.
But what do you do when your whatever 23
years old,
there's something that like particularly
in the human brain,
there's something that resonates about
hanging from something by your hands.
Like that's one of the scariest ones.
Like Kingston is on this gigantic crane
and he's hanging onto the crane with his
hands and then he does it with one hand.
He's hanging in there and he's fucking
hundreds of feet up and if he falls,
he's just.
He just a water balloon.
Oh,
but there's something about,
for some reason like balancing scary,
but hanging is really scary.
I'm the opposite.
Really?
Balances Scarier than hanging.
I'd rather hang.
I feel pretty,
pretty good hanging.
We don't do a lot of chips.
I don't feel good about the balancing
because I think I could trip and fall.
That's it.
What's the life expectancy of Kingston?
Not so good.
I mean,
he knows that,
right?
Yeah.
He's got to know that.
He's a smart guy too,
which is really weird and really calm.
Look at these fucking assholes.
Oh Jesus.
Oh my God.
This guy.
Folks,
if you listening,
this guy has a skateboard and he is on a
couple thousand feet in the fucking air.
Shit.
It's terrifying.
I mean,
how many of these guys die?
It's not that many.
That's what's weird about it.
I saw it.
I saw a video.
One guy for Happenin.
Oh really?
It didn't make it.
Where was it?
I Dunno.
Something somewhere in Russia.
Of course.
What was he doing?
He doing this walking around up on some
high.
Yeah.
This kid is getting.
They get right to the edge with
skateboards barefoot.
What the fuck dude?
What is that word?
Did you talk to him about how he,
how he built into this?
Did he start at 20 feet and then he went
to 30 feet and then he got more
confident?
No,
I don't think gene.
Well,
he's got the.
He's a smart guy.
He's a weird guy because you meet them.
You're expecting like I'm gonna talk to
this meth doubt psychopath who just
wants to just get a juice rush all day
long.
Now he's super calm and relaxed and
normal.
It's weird.
Doesn't make any sense.
But where did it start for him?
I don't know.
He's got a normal family.
Seems healthy.
Yeah,
he just likes it.
He pulled out a weird,
weird Alex Hall.
You had alex honnold.
Yeah.
And you know,
we,
my family,
we go up to Yosemite and stuff,
so we are familiar,
but you can see how he kind of edged
into it.
Right?
And you start climbing and you got ropes
and then you get really good at it and
then you're like,
you know what,
I can probably make it to there without
a rope.
And then next thing you know you're
probably make it there too.
And then the next thing you know you're
climbing El Capitan with no rope or
halftone with no rope,
which is completely,
you know somebody.
Yeah,
completely insane to even think about
that though.
He does some insane stuff where you're
going backwards,
like you're at a reverse degrees,
15 degrees the wrong way,
like any climbs up at to go above it and
he's got no ropes and he's just hang on
with hands.
It was like,
what the fuck dude?
He was telling us a story about one time
where he's halfway up the mountain.
He realized he forgot his powder.
So he ran into some other people that
were up there that were on ropes.
He said,
Hey,
can I borrow your powder?
Like a,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah bro,
pack powder bag at the top of the
mountain.
Like yeah,
I heard him talking about it,
that he,
for him it's not a big deal because he
knows how strong he is and he knows what
his limitations are so it doesn't for
it,
it's like he's comfortable with it.
Right.
He's comfortable.
It's like someone walking on a balance
beam that does it all the time.
They're going to be comfortable with it
and he's climbing stuff all the time.
So He's more company.
It's still hard to get a grip on though.
It's hard to get a grip.
You know,
when I was hosting fear factor,
we had this one thing that we did where
we had people hanging from a pole that
was suspended over this water and it was
shocking how slow like the least,
the little amount of time,
the small amount of time that men in
particular could hang from a pole.
Like they were like a minute and these
guys were dropping into the water and I
was like,
what the fuck?
Like women want it regular.
Yeah.
Women want it because they have have
lighter bodies.
So even though their hands might be
weaker,
like,
and one guy was fucking Jack,
there's like this football player
looking dude,
and he didn't make it man.
He was like a minute and 15 in,
plop it into the water.
I was like,
this is crazy.
I had,
I had a guy in my field training class
that was a big giant monster guy and he
couldn't complete the obstacle course.
No,
you know,
too many of clients.
Strength is too much,
too much mass behind you that you're
asking small limbs or small digits to
control.
And then also too much of your heart has
to pump too much blood through that
tissue.
There's like a point of diminishing
returns when it comes to size,
you know?
That's one of the things that you saw
when you see Cain Velasquez fight guys.
Cain Valasquez has always been in that
sweet spot of about 2:40
2:40
to me is about as big as you want to get
because the guys over to 40 men,
they might fuck you up in the first few
minutes,
but he take them into that fourth and
fifth minute of the first round and
they're huffing and puffing and then the
second round they're getting their asses
kicked and the Cain Velasquez storm was
the one of the more fascinating things
to watch in all my years of the UFC
because he was a heavyweight that had
the cardio of a lightweight,
but he was again,
240 pounds.
Oh well,
well marbled 240 pounds.
He's not like he was a lean.
No,
he had some.
He always looks a little bit.
He had a lot of Mexican food.
Some rice and beans eaten.
Lunch would be like for real,
like you like one of the elite
heavyweights ever and he's sitting there
with fucking 10 tacos and shit and you
know that's a talent to the.
Having that kind of sustained energy is
a talent.
Just like some guys are super flexible
and some guys are super strong and
explosive and some guys just have that
they can to have that range and what is
it?
Medium twitch muscles,
right?
It's medium twitch,
slow twitch.
You will know that twitch,
which is I'm a marathoner,
right?
And then there's fast twitch which is
almond Olympic weightlifter,
but in recent years they've said there's
actually something in the middle twitch
which is I'm strong but I can go for a
long time.
That's interesting.
I didn't know about that but it makes
sense and that's what I got like Kainos
because cane like you said,
I mean for him to be able to get in
there and go five rounds pushing away,
pushing around another guy that weighs
260 pounds.
Yeah,
that's beast mode right there.
There's a lot going on with Kane.
I think one thing is going on his
genetics,
he has incredible genetics and they,
they like Bob Cook would tell me that
cain would be out for months,
like get an injury and come back and
it's outwork everybody like it just
insane cardio.
So maybe it's also that his base was so
rock solid that his attache for three
months is everybody else's,
you know,
peak condition and what's one of the
reasons why he was able to overwhelm so
many people,
but also like when you see cain execute
things,
he's never straining like Cain.
Everything is perfect technique.
There's no like there's no like grunting
and forcing anything.
There's no like crazy look on his face
and like the windmill punches,
everything is clean and crisp and it's
all like very efficient.
Vishal movies and machine and obviously
that comes from training the heart.
And is that training hard to hard?
Has he been trying to or is that why
he's all dinged up then?
Yes.
Some flights because of injuries.
Well there's also the mind like his mind
is so strong that he's able to overcome
the feeling of pain.
But sometimes like elite athletes,
especially fighters,
they can't distinguish between what is
just like dings,
like everybody gets dinged up,
but something that's a significant
injury like,
hey,
you've got to compromise in the
structure of your body.
If you keep pushing it,
you're going to blow this knee out,
you're going to fuck this disk up,
you're going to need surgery,
and the caines had a gang of surgeries
now shoulder,
knees back and now you know,
he's been out for quite a while with
this most recent back issues and it
sucks because in my opinion it's like
him and Fader,
you know,
those are the two greatest heavyweights
of all time.
Interestingly,
same similar body style.
Yeah.
Thirty to 40.
Well marbled.
Yeah.
Feta,
feta or at its peak had like the
ultimate dad bod.
He had like a dad that used to play
rugby,
you know,
fuck guys up.
They'd post those videos though of him
training in Russia,
running with his buddies and swinging
kettlebells and yeah,
this guy works hard.
Oh yeah,
no doubt.
He just probably ate shitty food.
You had just tons of it,
you know.
But it's also like their methodology is
just different.
I mean he was very,
very old school with his methods,
like he was doing kettle bells but way
before crossfit or came to America.
I mean,
there was a,
there's an old school pictures,
see if he could find a jamie back when
he was jacked,
like he got smaller as his career went
on because he stopped doing strength and
conditioning as his body got older and
for focused more on skill work.
But there's this ancient picture,
not ancient,
but this is a picture of him standing
there shirtless around a bunch of
Kettlebell Kettlebell lecture,
2001 or something like that,
you know,
and the thing that I think that he
really had,
which he had a good,
his skill in my mind was that he was
really good.
Grapplers a really good striker,
but he,
the way he mixed them together,
you would see him just like hit somebody
in the face and then judo,
throw them into an arm,
lock them or choke them.
It was all just so smooth.
I don't think anyone knew what to defend
because if they defended one thing they
getting,
if they defended it,
uh,
grappling,
move,
they're getting punched in the face if
they do
defendant upon.
They were getting taken down.
Yeah,
he was something special man.
And you know,
he was something special for quite a
long time to.
I don't,
I don't think anybody can keep going
longer than like,
just like a time that you can compete at
the highest level.
Some folks think it's about eight,
nine years.
They're like an ad after eight,
The highest level.
Like nobody's body holds up,
it just all falls apart.
And you know,
as much as I'm talking good about fate
or in his style and everything,
let's face it.
What was the best about Fei door was his
attitude when he would just come in
there with no emotions raised his hand,
dead face,
you know,
they'd introduce him,
he just raised his hand and he'd destroy
someone and he would have the same space
like before he fought,
just had total absence of emotion.
That was to me,
that's what I always thought.
Yes,
that's right up there at the top of my
list.
So there's the picture.
Exactly.
Just jacked standing around a bunch of
fucking iron cannonballs with handles on
them.
And those aren't some little kittle
bills either.
Yeah,
I bet that picture alone must've sold
millions of dollars with kettlebells.
People saw that picture and they're
like,
I gotta get some at.
But he also was very smart.
It,
that's his brother actually.
He was very smart with his training
where,
you know,
he spent some time in Holland for him
and his brother,
like way back in the day,
the picture of his brother now and get a
picture of Alexander and he just got out
of jail.
I don't know,
I wonder if he's gonna fight again.
His brother was a bad motherfucker.
He was,
he's an animal.
He's got the uh,
there's something about Russians,
man.
For sure.
There are different kinds of white
people.
They totally different.
They just did so much different.
Well,
it's the hard upbringing.
Yo.
Yeah,
man.
Diamonds,
diamonds made out of pressure.
And the other guy that comes to mind
when we're thinking about old school
fighters that really,
it wasn't just his skill set,
which was unbelievable.
Sakharova [inaudible] the way soccer
Robert.
His craziness.
Oh yeah.
And just to go in there and just have
that incredibly playful attitude.
Also chain smoked and drank through this
entire camp chain.
Smoked and drank.
I went out with him in Japan after one
of his fights one time.
What did he do?
He was just getting after it.
But that attitude of not giving a fuck
is like,
that's what worked so well for them
inside the.
Inside the ring.
Yeah.
Well I know we see this all the time
with fighters.
We with anybody that is going to live
out on the fringe like that,
they're going to have some sort of
offset.
There's,
there's another,
there's for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction.
Right?
So you get a guy that's living that far
on the edge like soccer.
Robert was that,
that edge just doesn't stop when he gets
out of the kids.
Right.
Just going and going to get after it.
He had some horrible losses though.
He got,
he got,
you know,
used in an exploited worse than anyone
else.
Right.
I mean,
worse than any other fighter,
no one has been exploited and put into
those horrible flights where he just
wasn't out.
I mean,
he was just outmatched.
He was old,
he wasn't trained right.
And they would just put them in there
and just let them get destroyed.
Well,
his knees were mad so he would wrap his
knees up like a mummy.
Yeah,
they were horrible.
And you knew that that was a real
injury.
Like he,
uh,
like he couldn't move so good.
His knees were all wrapped up and fucked
up and then they put them in there with
vandelay and vandelay knocked him out.
What,
three times?
Brutal.
Brutal chaos,
I think at least twice.
I'm trying to think of it's two or three
times.
But um,
and then Melvin manhoef who,
whether it was soccer,
kicking them because you get soccer kick
and pride and stomp.
Yeah.
He had some really tough fights.
He's apparently doing a grappling super
fight now.
I think he's grappling.
He grappled Benzo.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
I was thinking of what I was actually
thinking of Shinya Aoki is going to
grapple with Gary Tonin.
Oh,
that'll be.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're going to have a straight up
grappling.
Yeah.
Garrett can fuck them up.
Most likely,
but I okies good man.
Especially now.
But it's a big difference between guys
who are good in mma and guys who are
good at like straight up grandpa and the
training vids of Gary,
just like he's just trained all the,
all,
all he does.
He's completely obsessed with Jujitsu.
I love it.
Yeah.
And he's doing rope climbs and he's
just,
that's all he does.
So he's also being coached by John
Donner and he's a part of that Henzel
Gracie crew in New York City.
And that Donna,
her death squad man,
you want to talk about a,
uh,
a real like wizard of Jujitsu.
Donna her understand his instagram posts
or some of the very best instagram posts
on the Internet.
I haven't.
I got to follow him then.
Oh,
you got it man.
His breakdowns of certain techniques and
matches and what went well,
what went wrong and what's required of
athletes and,
and how to excel and the difference
between an athlete and competition
versus a difference in training.
This one was the most recent things
about putting yourself in bad positions
and working on your weaknesses as
opposed to just continuing to push your
strengths.
Well,
that's a big one though.
The fighters that are good in training,
but they're not good at in their cage
and there's other fighters that are kind
of get beat up and training,
but then when they get in the cage,
they.
They rise to the occasion.
I got to see that a bunch with a bunch
of different fighters over the years
that I trained with and you'd say,
this guy is going to do okay,
but then they'd get in,
they'd get in the cage and boom,
they would just turn it on.
They elevate themselves and then some
guys that are crushing everyone during
training,
they get in the cage,
you know,
UFC fight night or whatever,
and they just,
they just can't.
They can't get it done that night.
Even though they're crushing people in
the draining.
Yeah.
There's so many factors.
Right.
And I think some of them are also the
ability to overcome adversity and with
really talented guys,
they didn't really have to overcome that
much adversity because they were good
really quickly.
Like guys who had massive physical
advantages.
And then for some reason,
you know,
once they faced other people that also
have physical advantages but were
tougher,
they would just go.
It just fall apart.
Just wilt.
Yeah.
It's so common.
You got to get that in.
And we got some guys that,
this guy at the gym right now who's
just,
he's just a,
he's a mutant.
He's a mutant.
Like he's so
strong.
He,
I hose it,
he shot on me the other day I sprawled
on him.
And so he's on all fours and he's,
he fights at one 85.
I'm on all fours and he picks me up with
one hand with one hand,
picks me up and slams me and gets across
side.
And I said,
Bro,
did you just like shot,
put me right there.
And 180,
he people walk around.
He walks around the 200,
two.
Oh five.
You know,
typical picture on the one hand,
one hand,
but not with his back,
but like with his arm,
you're going to see him,
Taylor Johnson,
watch out for him.
What is this background?
He wrestled,
he wrestled,
he it.
But this is the thing.
We know,
we know this right?
There's wrestlers that are great
wrestlers and they're.
And they're okay at Jujitsu but they
can't quite make that transition and
they're strikings okay.
But they can't quite make that
transition for whatever reason,
whatever gift he's got.
He saw the other day we were training
and he's been training.
This was a few months ago.
He's been training for like six months,
right.
And he dives for a commuter on me and I,
you know,
I move and get out and you know,
we keep training,
whatever,
and we get done.
He goes,
man,
you know,
I just,
I can't lock anything up on your,
you can't like I can't,
I can't get any finishes on you.
And I was like,
Bro,
you've been training for six months.
There's guys who have been training here
for 10 years that have never even
attempted a submission on me and you're
trying to submit me with mile,
move the camera.
I'm like,
Bro,
don't worry about it.
It's going to come.
So yeah,
it's it.
But my point is with him is he's an
incredible athlete and he's got that
work ethic too,
and so,
and he's competed at a high level and
wrestling,
you know,
he's an all American wrestler.
I think d two though,
but you know,
nonetheless he savage.
Yeah.
Pe,
there's the ability to compete.
It's a,
it's an interesting ability.
Like some people just don't have it or
they wore the.
It's not even that they don't have it.
They lack the mental skills to overcome
pressure filled obstacles.
Yeah.
And you're right.
And there's some people that step up
when that happens.
And can you train to do that?
I think you can think you can.
I think you can.
Do you inoculate yourself to the stress.
It's just the mind.
So like you like the idea that these
pitfalls and the mind are
insurmountable.
I think that's ridiculous.
That seems to be more surmountable or
more,
um,
uh,
more passable than physical problems
because like physical problems,
like if you're 140 pounds and the guys
240 pounds,
you're both equally talented and both
equally driven.
Boy,
you're fucked.
You're fucked.
Yeah.
Well,
that being said,
it is similar to what we talked about
earlier,
which is when you have somebody that's
caught in their own mind,
they can't get the perspective to step
out.
You're like,
dude,
just calm down.
Just kind of freak out about.
You're going to go in there.
What if I lose it?
She loses no big deal.
We'll get around.
It will train more.
It's no big deal.
They can't get over that.
And so you do get people that get
trapped in their minds.
And I mean there's all kinds of fighters
that have gone through that never came
out of it.
Well,
there's a really important quote.
If you win,
you win.
If you lose,
you learn.
And so you always win.
And if you really
can think about it that way,
every time I remember pretty much every
time I've ever been humiliated on the
Mat,
every time I've ever been,
like really manhandled and tapped,
I remember them very well.
And I also remember like every time I
rolled with like a real high level
Blackville and got my ass handed to me,
my training jumped up a notch because
like,
uh,
you know,
that expression,
the rub,
like you train with someone who's way
better and you know,
you realize like,
oh,
there's a whatever I thought was like a
high frequency.
There's people that are operating like
several hundred rpms faster than that.
And I just hadn't encountered them,
you know.
And I think that to be around that is so
important.
If you ever trained with a guy that like
trains in a small town and uh,
all the people in the town is like maybe
like a purple belt coaches and they,
they have like a,
there's a certain rpm that they all
operate in.
And if you come in and you're used to
that fucking San Diego assassin,
rpm.
And they like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
Like they're just not used to it.
They have or.
But if you come from a place like that
and you try to train it,
hence or something like that,
like you're dealing with you jumping
into a fucking pit of killers like,
and that's,
you know,
that old expression,
iron sharpens iron.
Who could not be more true when it comes
to Jujitsu.
Oh,
there's no doubt.
The better people you train with,
the better you're going to get and
you've got to seek those people out.
You know,
you got to not mind.
Hey,
that Guy Taylor,
that I'm talking about do,
do I like getting my ass kicked by a guy
that's been training for six months.
No,
I hate it.
I hate it Taylor.
But guess what?
I call them out every time and I talk
smack to him.
I don't talk a bunch of smack talking
I'm like,
Hey,
what's up young buck,
you want to come get some of this
everyday?
Because I want to train with him because
he's that strong need.
Of course I'm training with Dean,
I'm training with Jeff Glover.
I train with those guys too,
but the young buck that wants to get
after it a little bit more.
Yeah,
we'll also.
There's something about freak wrestling
strength.
That's just.
It doesn't make any sense.
Like I've,
I've rolled with restaurants before.
I'm like,
okay,
whatever you are.
There's,
there's people and then like,
like chimp chimp person,
you know,
they have like when your body is used to
from the time you're an early kid
throwing bodies around like your tendon
strength and your ability to manipulate
bodies is a very different kind of
strength.
I mean it might not translate to a 40
yard dash or or sprint or you know,
lifting weights,
but there's the physical ability to move
bodies is very unusual.
Yeah,
and you always have to be careful too
because there's been plenty of wrestlers
along the way that don't do well in mma.
They just,
they're great,
they're strong,
but I think that's a mental thing.
I think they have some limited factor in
their brain where they go,
they just can't quite open their mind to
Jujitsu.
They can't quite open their mind to
striking.
They can't get out of that wrestler
mentality of,
you know this,
I have to go as hard as I can right now
because you can't go as hard as you can
run out for the whole time.
You will run out of gas.
Especially with striking.
If you're.
If you're boxing and with people and you
think
you're just going to go in and do that,
you're going to run into somebody who
actually knows how to box and you're
going to come home with headaches every
night.
You're going to get very discouraged.
It's a matter of who you're training
with too,
like as far as your trainer is like,
who's who's coaching you and what
methodology are they using and what,
what mindset are they trying to impart
on you as far as like skill development
because there's so many people out there
that just don't have like a real clear
philosophy.
Like they don't have a goal.
Like in terms of like I want to work on
footwork in avoiding certain shots and
being able to move in better.
You know,
instead they're just trying to win every
round or they're trying to push hard and
then do you not get to the next level,
which in my mind when we get past the
athleticism,
we get past the mental overcoming of
challenges and then in my opinion,
you get to the next level which is
creativity and that's when you get to
Mcgregor,
right?
Jonny Bones Jones,
they're doing things that they're kind
of making up and they're making them up
live as they go.
And I think that to me is,
is,
you know,
we kind of,
I think we saw with Bj Penn back in the
day,
he was creative,
I think fate or did it where he was,
he was doing creative things.
But I think to me that's,
that's where you go that one level
higher is when you add the creative
element to a guy that can take a and B
and make f out of those things somehow.
Yeah.
And when you watch those guys,
there's something about watching a Jon
Jones or fate or a prime time Bj Penn.
It elevates you.
You watch someone do somethIng special
like that.
And you just walk out of there,
you feel like,
I know I can run faster than I could
before I saw that fight.
I know I could.
I could lift more weights.
I know I could do something better.
Just people.
I think this is a huge thing that one of
the reasons why people enjoy watching
all kinds of sports,
but in particular combat sports.
When people do something amazing,
it makes you feel like amazing things
are possible.
Yeah.
I actually,
I have limitations on that too because
personally I'll watch somebody,
you know,
some random fighter or whatever and I'll
say,
I could,
I could probably do that.
You knoW what I mean?
Like,
I could do that.
That's a good fighter,
but I could.
I'm good at jujitsu.
I'm pretty good striker.
I could do that.
And then occasionally see a guy and I
go,
no,
you know what?
I could not do what that guy can do.
It just makes me,
it,
it's,
it's humbling.
It's humbling.
I was wanting,
you know,
Jack Black,
Jack Black.
I was watching Jack Black the other day
and I look at Jack Black.
I look at some,
I look at some actor,
right?
I look at brad pitt and I go,
what,
what's brad pitt do?
And I could do what he's doing.
He's talking on the movie screen,
whatever.
I know I'm underestimating this.
Right?
But that's what I'm thinking.
I'm like,
you know,
I could do that.
But also I was watching Jack Black and
Jack Black was singing and I was like,
I can't do it.
Jack black's doing right there,
respect and prompts to you.
The homeboys got pipes,
right,
got pipes And I looked at the same.
I look
at,
you know,
at jonny bones jones and I go,
I wouldn't have done what he just did.
I look at ge at,
at mcgregor and I go,
you know what he's got?
He's got some little spark that I don't
have.
He's got a flare.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a flare that mcgregor has.
It's half of what he does.
I mean,
he's unbelievably talented.
He's got ridiculous power,
but there's also this flare about him
when he fucking walks in,
they're flinging his arms and then he
stands there and farm his opponent and
goes like that.
There's some about him,
the,
the fucking audaciousness of his,
you know,
he's just so ridiculous,
but it was really impressed me when he
came back and beat nate.
Really impressed.
I thought it was a very close fight.
I put,
I actually don't have to watch it again.
I usually don't watch fights more than
once,
but I know it was very,
very close.
They could have won that fight.
Yeah,
I thought so too.
But it didn't.
And even just as close as it was,
I was impressed and that was,
I think,
one of the most impressive feats I've
seen as far as that mental game.
We're talking about to come back and
say,
you know what?
I'm going to,
I'm going to do it this time that he
even wanted to come back 70 again.
That was at one 70,
right?
The second time.
It was very Impressive.
You know,
a lot of people don't know that he had a
pretty bad staph infection just a few
weeks before the first fight and he was
on some serious antibiotics and that's
one of the reasons why he was so
drained.
Like people are calling you gassed out,
like if you've never taken antibiotics
before,
you don't know how fucking horrible it
is on your gas tank.
It's one of the weirdest thing ever.
So you can be in great shape.
You get on a run of antibiotics and your
body's just you gotta fucking thimble
gas tank.
There's nothing left.
You've got no energy for whatever
reason.
You just can't push yourself through
stuff.
And I think that played a factor in that
fight.
And here's the thing about mcgregor.
He never had a fucking peep about it.
If it wasn't for me talkIng about it,
most people wouldn't even know that.
Yeah,
he's a bad mother fucker and I don't
know.
I don't mean they said he signed the
floyd mayweather deal.
Yep.
He signed.
When did that happen?
It didn't happen yesterday.
He,
he has sIgned floyd mayweather.
Has not signed.
They're negotiating the naloxone.
Yup.
Pure boxing.
Yeah.
So the right thing.
I'm like,
people click.
I mean maybe he's going to go full
bernard hopkins just fucking clench and
hit him in the clench and tie him up and
rough them up.
And maybe that's the plan,
lean on his neck,
you know,
just fIght dirty,
let them take points away.
Who gives a shit logo,
get disqualified,
don't stand in the middle of the ring
and try to fuck and shuck and jive with
them.
But the other thing is,
is not knocking a lot of people out.
You know,
it's a good fight in terms of like to
see what the fuck happens.
Yeah.
How much money is that gonna make he's
gonna make a fuck.
Ton of money.
He's gonna make that he estimated.
I don't know if it's true between 75 and
$100,000,000
on a and then who knows how much floyd's
going to make somewhere in that range to
maybe more,
probably more.
But I think that it's going to be
interested.
First of all,
floyd's 40,
almost 41.
Floyd's maybe the best defensive boxer
that's ever walked the face of the
planet.
I mean he's right up there.
And my.
I mean,
you can go back to willy pap,
a lot of the guys from the old days and
for sure loma chanko today,
but in terms of overall performance
against elite fighters over the course
of his career,
the guy's only been tagged hard like
five or six times ever.
He's a fucking freak and hard work.
I mean,
he,
he's uh,
you look at him,
he's throwing money around driving
bentleys,
but that fucking guy will get on the
strip and he'll be running miles at 3:00
in the morning.
He opens up hIs gym,
3:00
in the morning,
just does 15 rounds of the bag.
Just,
he works hard.
I mean,
I don't know if he works that hard
anymore.
That'll be an interesting one.
Fuck yeah,
I'll watch it.
I hope it goes down.
He might get as connor,
my kid his ass handed to him,
but he might not.
He might tack floyd.
I mean if he can.
Connor is very good at closing distance
and snapping off like lead shots.
Like that's one of the things that he
did with nate and he's a southpaw.
If he can just snap off one or two clean
shots and make an interesting,
it'll be fun.
I don't know if he can.
I don't know what he can do.
Straight box.
It's so hard to judge.
Come on to judge without,
without knowing,
without soon.
And if they do do it,
I think they're going to do it somewhere
around september.
I think that's the idea.
Jesus christ.
So what's he doing with the ufc?
But until then,
nothing.
Nothing.
So the lightweight division is on
hostage right now.
They're being held hostage interim
something or whatever.
I'm supposed to do that.
But fucking habib.
Norma got sick trying to make the weight
and didn't make the way.
What happened there?
Tony ferguson and habib.
We're supposed to fight in a bebes
liver.
Shut down.
Yeah,
he's cuttIng too much weight.
These guys,
they get too fucking big.
You know,
they get up to 190 and they try to get
down to 1:55
and he couldn't make it.
Was he walking around at one point?
I don't know.
That's what I heard.
I don't know what he really weighed,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
for sure.
Habib's grappling is so super high
level.
I want to see.
I wanted to see that fight so bad
because tony ferguson is a fucking
savage.
He's a straight savage,
so him versus habib,
like I watched that fight with him and
edson barboza again the other day,
crazy fucking wild blood bath until tony
caught him with a doris was a fucking
amazing fight.
Like that's the guy I want to see fight
a guy who's one of the only guys
undefeated at the top level of the game,
which is habib.
He said only god.
It's like a top contender that's
undefeated and it's smashed everybody in
front of it.
How much longer until he can fight
again.
Who knows if you'll ever be able to make
1:55
again.
who knows?
Who knows what kind of damage was done
to his body and these rapid,
rapid,
horrible weight cuts.
I don't know,
man.
I don't.
I don't know his medical history,
his medical history or medical issues,
but I know before the Michael Johnson
fight,
apparently he had a similar problem.
He made the weight,
but apparently it was real touch and go,
yeah,
can't do that.
No,
you got to cut your calories back.
You mean you want to suffer,
cut your calories back,
do a lot of fucking running,
drop some body weight.
You're going to have to and it can be
done.
It can be done.
You have to do it because rapid
dehydration,
you're going to fucking die.
Someone's going to die in the ufc is
just pass some new weight cutting rules
and new weight classes.
It was like.
This is from andy foster.
Andy fosters the guy who runs California
as a state athletic commission and he is
such a fucking animal.
Any foster is one of the most important
guys in terms of like commission.
The guys who run commissions in mma,
he's like one of the most proactive,
one of the most knowledgeable and one of
the very best,
maybe the best.
He's so on the ball and so he's pushed
hard for these new weight classes and
these new weight cutting regulations and
such a fucking smart thing.
That guy's.
That guy's awesome man.
I like the 25 weight class.
Even the one 95.
Weight class 10,
they should skip 70 and do 10 every.
Every two.
Twenty five.
Thirty five,
45.
Fifty five,
65.
Just go 10.
Every 10 is good.
10.
Makes sense.
When you got to like 70 and then you've
got 85 and they get 85 and two.
Oh five.
That's too many.
That's too many pounds.
I mean gsp versus what were they going
to.
Gsp versus bisping?
Yeah.
I've tried to explain this to people
because I've been in the room and stood
next to those guys.
Busy being is a big,
big,
big man.
He is.
The gsp is a normal sized guy.
I don't see how that fight was going to
be fair.
You know?
Also bisping is currently active.
Gsp took years off.
Bisping is capable of fighting at 55.
He says.
Bisping said he could make 55.
Wow.
Yeah,
so if he wins at one 81,
85,
he has thought about fighting either at
one 70 or at 1:55.
Like what the fuck?
He's a big dude straw.
I've trained with him.
He's a big strong.
He's what?
Six two,
something like that.
bisping.
He's tall,
he's big.
He's got a fucking incredible cardio for
sure.
He's a hard worker.
Yeah.
That guy is a perfect example of just
like the ultimate,
like bulldog mindset and just refusing
and now looking at is the chair and he
took that fight on a week's notice,
two weeks notice against rockhold when
that's not even that.
I think it Was a few days.
I think it was like 11 days notice or
something crazy.
Just being pissed.
Talking shits.
Dana white on twitter because he was mad
at gsp.
Got a title shot and he hasn't earned
the title shot.
Yeah.
He's like,
what the fuck the gsb do and oh man,
the whole,
the whole way classes in a flux and
there's a funny meme of a [inaudible].
Bisping said that he's his knees hurt
because they said that the ufc said they
want them to fight you el ramiro because
the gsp fight is off.
And he's like,
oh,
actually my knees hurt.
So uh,
I could wait for gsp.
He was like,
I can't really train right now.
I'm good.
I'm just going to sit back and take a
little break.
So there's a funny meme,
gsp,
michael bisping in the hospital bed that
says bisping be like,
I'll just sit here and wait for gsp.
Yoel savage,
terrifying.
But that really bummed me out.
When tim kennedy asked him,
well,
that was cheating.
Yeah.
That shouldn't have happened.
Was cheating and that,
that was horrible.
Tim did a little bit of cheating.
That fight too.
What do you do?
He grabbed his gloves.
He's grabbed the inside of the glove,
punched him in the face a couple times
while I was holding urls.
Glove,
but do.
But people show that in slow motion.
But what they don't understand is you're
showing slow motion,
like it looks like he's holding onto it
for awhile and punching in real life.
It was less than a second or maybe a
second,
and it's probably just chaos and he's
grabbing something just throwing shit
whether or not he actually knew that he
had his glove consciously.
The gloves make a really big difference.
Huge grappling.
Huge.
You got to train with them.
If you're going to fight with them,
you know,
secure and chokes.
I mean,
even damien maia,
you see him get rear naked,
choke with a hand on top of the head,
like old school,
ken shamrock style.
Like he'll,
he'll,
because he can't get the hand back
there.
He just can't get it and people start
grabbing new idea.
Team people are grabbing the inside of
that glove.
It's hard.
It's a lot harder to finish stuff.
People have gloves on.
Well,
some people finish with it.
Josh thompson used to grab his own
glove,
which you can do.
You can get deep in there.
I saw him choke somebody out with that.
I was like,
woo,
you can do that.
I think you can grab your own glove and
that makes a nice handle if you can slip
your fingers in there to train with
them.
If you're going to fight with them,
you have to have,
oh,
it's amazing how hard it is to choke
people when you have those,
especially those gloves.
A big pat of ones.
Even marcello garcia was having a really
hard time with it.
When he had his one loan mma fight,
he had this dude's back and he couldn't
finish them in.
A lot of it is because of those.
Does that make a big difference?
They really do.
I don't think you should wear gloves.
I really don't.
I totally agree with you.
I think fighting.
If you could kick somebody in the shin
to the face,
like you can shoot somebody in the face,
but you can't knuckle in the middle.
I think it would be so helpful for all
the head trauma that's happening.
If they took off the gloves and you add
either strike with an open palm or you
had to pay the price because I might hit
you twice before I broke my hand and now
I'm going to be grappling with you and
trying to take her down.
I don't think people understand that,
that if someone just ducks their head
down and you hit them with a straight
punch to the forehead,
you are very likely to break your hand.
I don't think you'd be able to wrap your
hands either.
I really don't.
That would be awesome.
That would be.
You should have.
I think you should have a cop on and a
mouthpiece and shorts and I really think
that's it.
I mean,
and people like,
oh,
you're a fucking idiot.
You're a barbarian.
They need to cover the globe.
No,
they don't.
You're,
you're less of a barbarian.
You make yourself.
You make yourself more able to hit
someone and you don't really help them
at all.
Like it's harder to hit someone bare
knuckle.
Yeah.
Like it's,
it's more realistic.
I wish they would make that change and I
wish that would change everything,
but when you can elbow somebody but you
can't bare knuckle,
that's crazy.
Your knuckles are way more vulnerable.
Like gets way harder to to get that off
until you wrap it up.
Then you make it like a cast.
You wrap it up and you get some.
You'll look like a nice stiff
restaurant.
We rips.
Risk isn't going anywhere.
Buckling and flexing.
When you punched someone,
it's hard core when they wrap up those
hands.
Boy,
like even like holding pads for guys
when we're backstage getting ready to
take there.
Did they just turn it up?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but they'll never make that change.
I don't saY I don't think it should and
I think for really for the head trauma
of the people that are fighting is that
that's really needed for sure the head
all those times and it's not good for,
you know,
it's not good for you.
And agaIn that goes back to the
grappling thing.
I think we see more submissions.
I think it would be way easier to catch
people with stuff like it'd be way
easier to secure good teens and chokes.
It's just you,
you,
you wouldn't have all these restrIctions
of having something on your hands.
Your hands need to be able to articulate
and move to secure certain grips and
you'd see you'd see a lot more
submissions.
I think it's too bad they don't make
that change.
it'd be better for everyone.
Yeah.
I mean,
I remember when I first started working
for the ufc,
you didn't have to wear gloves.
Vituro was one of the first guys to
wear.
I'm victorian tank tank was one of the
first guys ever to wear gloves and he
wore those gloves that he was wearing
were like old school century martial
arts,
chuck norris gloves like nobody had even
thought to wear those.
I think tank was like the innovator,
the innovator for sure.
Then vito or innovative design head.
Yeah,
but,
but pop,
pop,
pop.
Damn.
And v tour.
In the early days I was there,
his first fight in 1997.
The first time ufc 12.
Nobody had seen anything like that.
This guy comes in with this blazing hand
speed built like a fucking greek god and
everybody's like,
oh jesus,
what do you do with this fucking kid?
That was,
that was interesting.
And of course we all hurt because I was,
you know,
jujitsu guy at that time were like,
oh,
he's only a purple belt is what we were
hearing.
And they gave him this black belt just
because he's doing this flight and blah
blah blah.
He's only a purple belt and he comes out
just,
what Is it,
13 punches to the face but pop pop.
And then he did the same thing to
vandelay pop,
pop,
straight punches down the pipe.
Crazy.
Yeah.
When he fought vandelay was wearing
shoes.
I remember that he was wearing like
wrestling shoes because all these wacky
rules back then,
it's really interesting to see like from
1993 to 2017,
how far fighting has changed and how
much we know about it now.
I always say that fighting in 1992 was
theoretical and,
and we,
you know,
some,
somebody will say something to me on the
internet like hey you know,
what about this martial art or whatever.
And I'm like what do you think of this?
And I'm like,
ah,
you just no reason to theorize.
Not only do we know from the ufc,
we also have been a now a country at war
for whatever,
15 years.
So all of our guys been going overseas
and doing the same stuff all in combat.
So we know what works.
There's no,
there's no big question anymore.
Right.
It's not like,
oh,
I wonder what happens if you poke a guy
in the.
I know.
We know what happens.
Yeah.
It's pretty obvious.
It's not good.
He here's another thing like like wing
chung and things like that.
Like,
yeah,
that'll work.
If the guy doesn't know what the fuck
he's doing and you chain punch them,
don't.
It's not good.
Hit somebody 17 times in the head are
not expecting that.
He's never trained before.
Definitely not good.
Very effective.
Are you going to get that off on someone
who actually knows what they're doing?
I don't know,
man.
Let me get that off on a high school
wrestler.
Good luck.
You're going flying into your head on
the curb.
Yeah.
It just.
It just seems to me that like.
Did you see that video?
That is becoming a huge issue in China
as a chinese tai chi master tried to
fight an mma fighter and just got a
glitter rated in 10 seconds and this guy
has had to hide.
This chinese mma fighters had to go into
hiding because people are offended that
he battered this tai chee master and
made their country look bad because it's
making their,
their traditional martial art look
ineffective.
That's not a.
That doesn't make sense to me.
Here.
we can watch this real quick,
but I don't know why the fuck this guy
didn't understand what was going to
happen when they fought.
They sometimes.
I think they actually believe what
they're saying.
This is so brutal though.
This chee guy.
What's really bizarre is tight.
She's not really a physical fighting
martial art.
It's supposed to be somethIng that's
more of like a meditative yoga.
It's like a yoga deal.
It's supposed to be grateful.
I had one of my,
one of my buddIes,
a black belt,
a guy named jeff higgs,
old school jujitsu guy,
and he got told by a thai guy,
you know,
you can't take me down.
Oh god.
And my buddy see that.
Yeah,
I mean that guy just got obliterated and
the only way you can ever actually know
what would happen if someone punches you
in the face is to train.
That way if you just have these ideas in
your head,
you're going to stand in front of them.
This guy just oozing blood all over the
place and he's getting up.
He's battered his nose shattered,
wobbly.
I guess first time it's ever been
punched.
Maybe the mma guy should have,
if he had a little bit more foresight.
and what was gonna happen?
He should've come out and you're like
really done the whole,
you know,
respect and then the bow and then all
this stuff and then after defeated him
should have helped him if he,
if he maybe that would have helped him
from a,
from a political standpoint.
Uh,
but Yeah,
he can wonder.
But,
you know,
it seems to me that this is something
that they need to see.
They really do because there's too many
people out there that are just buying
into this foolish shit.
we'll,
like I said,
so my buddy jeff higgs got this,
uh,
this,
I think it was an aikido guy.
Does I?
Quito people say cI and all that.
I don't know ci,
they probably do.
Well,
depends on which asshole you're talking
to them,
whether it was I quito or whether it was
a tie chee,
I forget,
but the guy says,
you know,
hey,
I'm a martial artist and once I settle
my ci,
you,
you can't even take me down.
So how are you going to do jujitsu on
me?
And he says,
weLl,
what do you mean you can settle your
cheeks as you know,
I,
once I sent her my ci and it's based
into the ground,
you won't be able to move me,
you can try if you want.
And my friend higgs goes,
okay,
cool.
Tell me when your cheese all centered
and the guy you know,
does thIs little thing and then settled
this g.
And he says,
okay,
I'm ready.
And jeff just did.
I mean,
it's no big deal,
just hit a double leg on a boom,
you know,
like you can't stop a double leg without
defending here when I was bawling and
yeah,
so,
so let's say the guy actually believed
that the guy actually believed that
that's the type of mental illness it is.
BuT I mean,
you know,
it's flat earth,
right?
It's this.
I want to bring that up right now,
but it's so often on this podcast,
I've got a couple people that are now.
Every time I talk about jujitsu at all,
they're like flat earth,
flat earth.
They believe it.
People believe it.
I get fucking shit every day from people
that are flatter with supporters that
are mad at me for exposing.
They just want to believe it.
That's real.
It is.
It is a weird thing with,
and by the way,
one of the main guys who send a flat
earth makes,
has a whole vIdeo about how jujitsu
doesn't work and it's about wing chung
isn't there like one of his biggest
videos on this page?
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
But there is something about people
wanting to believe that there's
mysteries and secrets that there's some
secret power,
like,
and that,
you know,
the idea that you could just center
yourself and a college wrestler can't
take you down.
That's one of my new thIngs that I tell
people with youtube because I used to
say like,
jujitsu is magic because it kind of is,
you know,
when you know jujitsu,
you can do things that are almost magic.
But then when you're teaching somebody
for the first time,
I'm always like,
look,
it's an,
it's not magic.
It's,
I always shown when somebody the other
day,
uh,
you know,
elbow escape or something from the
mount.
And the guy's like,
hey,
you know,
he's,
it's really hard to do because he keeps
pulling my arm away,
you know?
And I was like,
yeah,
it's a fight urine.
It's not magic.
It's you have to fight against the other
person to another human.
I Just told him what to do and I told
you what to do.
Now you've got to fight for it.
You've got to figure out how to get to
the right position.
It's not magic,
but it is weird that people that,
you know,
they're,
they're looking for something to believe
in I guess,
and maybe they just want a contrarian
viewpoints,
so that's why they picked saying that
the earth is flat.
Well,
I also think it's,
it's sorta the same thing with people
wanting shortcoming from going down this
road right now.
I just want to walk away and of podcast.
I'm out.
people love shortcuts.
They love,
they love,
like throwing out the entire paradigm of
modern civilization.
It's all based on a lie.
We're not on a globe worn a flat disc
deal.
Universe spins around us like,
you know,
people that just like to argue is this
maybe just people that like to argue and
have a country that could be some of
them for sure.
That could be some of them.
For some of them,
I think it's just that there are people
that straight up just straight up
believed that the earth is 100 percent.
One hundred percent your soul.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They really belIeve it.
But there's also people that joined the
moonies.
You know,
there's people that joined silent
scientology.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
there's people
out there that'll suck a dick if they
think it will make them live forever.
They suck your dick on my live forever.
Yes,
the knowledge will flow through you,
but you have to believe down in san
diego,
I don't know what it was 10 years ago,
15 years ago,
they had that heaven's gate thing.
We're Almost done.
Those purple shoes,
they put on the purple nike's and they
killed themselves in.
The comment was flying by and it shows
you again,
you know,
now we're talking about the human mind
is just so complicated and complex that
it's grasping for something to believe
in and some people aren't gonna believe
in anything.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's one of the things that guy richie
brought up the other day about your book
extreme ownership and It's one thing
that I think you and I are both really
focused on is the way the brain works
and the way the mind works,
and this is one of the things that I
think that you reinforce with these big
photos of your watch every day.
It's like the mind works in very
peculiar ways and you can and it's kind
of pliable and you could force it into
positive,
productive ways.
You can.
You can,
you can express yourself in these very
positive productive ways and in,
in,
in carve those grooves of productivity
and of advancement.
Well,
it's what you're talking about it.
we just talked about the moonies and the
scientology where people are trying to
do mind control and when I talk about
mind control,
I'm talking about controlling your own
mind.
You know,
you can make yourself exactly what
you're just saying.
You can make yourself and force yourself
to do things and once you get in that
groove and get in that habit,
it becomes part of you and that becomes
who you are and why not be that person.
Then the other person that's not doing
positive things.
Yeah,
but people like people like to also
pretend that the way they're doing it as
the right way,
they don't want to be open to the idea
that there's some other method that's
maybe more productive and more
successful who?
Well,
there's the downfall.
I mean,
and that's,
you know,
again,
and I,
I think this is one of the reasons why
your show is so popular and why people
listen to you because you,
you,
you listen to other people,
right?
People listen to you because you listen
to other people.
You listen to what they have to say.
You go,
okay,
that's an interesting viewpoint.
It hadn't heard that before and you.
I'm the same way when somebody tells me,
hey,
this is what I believe.
I don't say,
well,
I don't believe that.
I believe something else.
I go,
that's interesting.
That's an interesting viewpoint.
Yeah.
I always want to try to see things from
other people's perspective and it's hard
because the brain wants to go,
fuck this guy,
this guy,
no shit.
You're,
you're right,
dude,
this guy's wrong.
But you always got to like pause and
think.
I mean,
again,
I hate to bring this back up,
but that could easily be what's also
going on with the flat earth thing
because they have this idea in their
head and then someone's,
you know,
there's no photos of the earth other
than composites.
If there really was around earth,
you'd be able to see a hole and you go,
oh,
actually there's a photo taken every 10
minutes from 22,000
miles away,
have the full earth,
whoa,
well that's not true.
Well,
that's fake,
and they get into this thing and they
get into this thing because they don't
want to ever and pause and
look at the way they're thinking versus
the way other people were thinking,
okay,
did I get myself in a fucking trap here
that I get myself into an intellectual
trap where I'm supporting an idea that's
not true and now I'm reinforcing that in
my head and I'm fucking tightening up
all my my borders and trying to figure
out a way to not let new ideas in and to
to reinforce my old ideas.
You know your podcast with Jordan
Peterson the other day.
He kind of brought that up,
which by the way,
if anyone hasn't listened to that
podcast,
that's.
That's gotta be one of the best podcasts
that I've ever heard.
He's a mindblower unbelievable podcast
and he's talking about the fact that
sometimes people,
if they,
if they accept those new ideas,
all of a sudden what they've done with
their life for the past 20 years gets
thrown out the window.
Yeah,
and that's got to be really hard and
immediately when I was listening to
that,
I was thinking to myself,
yeah,
that's.
That's what happened in the nineties
when somebody that had been studying
some traditional martial art,
god bless them.
They were doing the best they could,
but when all of a sudden something blue
belt in jujitsu could come in there and
roll them up and choke them out and
there was nothing they could do about it
and they either had to do one of two
things,
say,
okay,
I'm going to start training this other
new thing that I don't understand or
block it out.
WhIch was very hard to do with jujitsu.
I mean that's the good thing about mma
and about ufc is it was like,
oh,
you can deny it all you want,
but you have to face this guy on the
mat.
That's the only way you can.
And when you do that,
you're goIng to lose.
whereas with all these kind of
intellectual arguments,
a lot of times it's just I say you say,
I say you say,
and if you tell me,
if I'm telling you that every picture of
the earth is whatever,
cgi,
and that's what I'm going to hold and
I'm not going to let it go and how you
going to prove to me otherwise in every
single picture you showed me,
I say no,
that cgi and you show me another
picture.
And I say to her that cgi,
we're never going to get anywhere.
I'm not arguing with you about it.
You're never going to tap just to turtle
up in a ball.
I had to go through three of those men
because I started out with taekwondo,
which was.
It's not like the,
it's not a good martial art for
fighting.
It's got a by itself.
It's got too many holes in it,
but it's a great martial art for
throwing kicks.
And when I went from that to kickboxing,
I realized how easy it was to get
punched in the face.
And I was like,
wow.
And so then I started really studying
boxing and I was like,
man,
my,
my ideas of like,
how well I can fight or so
overestimated.
I'm not nearly as good at taekwondo,
I'm not good at fighting.
And then I started doing more tie and
I'm like,
oh well,
fucking leg kicks,
Jesus christ,
leg kicks and knees to the body.
And the.
I was like,
oh fuck,
there's so much I can.
I'm so fucked now Because I got,
I got really good at something that kind
of sucks on its own.
And then from there jujitsu where I was
just getting raped,
I was like,
at least with kickboxing,
I could throw kicks,
I could move around,
I could try not to get my legs kicked,
I could try to like be more mobile.
But when I was going into Jujitsu as a
white belt,
I was just getting fucking mall to what
happens.
And I had accepted.
And then so I literally stopped doing
everything else and they said,
oh,
I've got to get Better at this in a way
I can.
You can't even start like,
oh white.
But some of us never train jujitsu
before is it has a zero percent chance
of beating a guy that's a black belt.
He has zero,
zero percent chance that they're not
goIng to go down.
If you take somebody that doesn't really
know how to fight against a boxer there,
there is a puncher's chance.
I mean there's a punch or she's not
probably not going to happen,
but it's a crazy chance.
But it could end.
At least the the person that hasn't
boxed before has some semblance of an
idea of what to do.
Block the punches from hitting me and
try and punch the other guy.
Right.
When you don't know Jujitsu,
you don't even understand what's
happening.
You're completely lost.
Yeah.
And there's certain positions like if
you get your Back taking or something
like that where you're almost 100
percent dead.
Yeah,
it's.
But I think that there's parallels to
that in life because if you look at life
and you look at the way you're behaving
and the way you're thinking and the way
you choose to accept Ideas and the way
that you choose to view the world,
if you're so rigid in your ideology that
you're unwilling to accept any sort of
new information and new data or any sort
of contrary data or information like
someone who's telling you something that
you don't agree with,
but you,
you're going,
okay,
well,
all right,
well what's your perspective?
Instead of Just agreeing or disagreeing
with them and arguing and going to war
with them,
try to take it in.
Try to go,
okay,
well what is this guy saying that has
merit?
Where's this guy coming from?
Or if I.
Even if I totally disagree with them,
what?
What makes him think this?
Like where?
What's going on in your head that you
think that we should take everyone's
money and distriButed equally across the
country.
Like there's people that believe that,
that everyone who's ever been successful
somehow or another got through stealing
and then what we need to do is take all
the money in the country and
redistribute all this.
Well so everybody gets $50,000.
okay,
well why do you think this?
Cool?
Yeah,
I want to know.
You know I'm not.
I might argue with it or I might see
your point or I might think that if you
did do this,
but you still,
if you did this right now,
this is what I think if you did this
right now,
if you took all the money from all the
billionaires and all these fucking rich
tycoons,
all of them and took all theIr money and
distributed it equally amongst everybody
in the country,
how long would it take if you just
allowed normal capitalism to flourish
after that,
how long would it take before the levels
went right back to where they are?
Would it be 10 years?
Would it be 20?
How long would it take
belong?
The way I explained that concept to my
children was I said,
okay,
here's,
here's what communism is,
because this is what you're talking
about.
I said,
let's.
My kids are really hard workers and they
do well in school,
and I said,
you know,
you study hard for your test,
right?
Let's say you get a nInety,
95 on your test and then what happens
with communism is there's another kid in
your class who's the dumbest kid,
billy,
okay,
billy's getting up,
whatever,
a third now.
So what we're gonna do is you're going
to take the test and then we're going to
take whatever points from you and given
to Billy so that you both get a d and
that's
what we're going to do now.
That's what communism missing.
Now if I do that,
is that can insPire you to work any
harder.
the answer's obviously no,
you're not going to.
You're going to get a d no matter what.
Is it going to inspire billy to work any
harder?
The answer is no.
It is not,
but he's not going to work any harder.
So what we have is no one working and
that's what happens in communism.
You're,
you're all just level set.
You're all gonna get the same thing and
that's why it's failed everywhere.
It's tried.
Yeah.
It's not the right idea for just the way
the human reward system works.
It's not the right idea for motivation.
It's not a ride,
right idea for like the only way things
get done and the only way you get a
laptop or a Big skyscraper,
someone has to profit from it.
They have to get something out of it.
And by the way,
someone has to make that haPpen.
Someone has to be driven to want that
laptop and to want that skyscraper.
Somebody got a want to make that and
you're right for them to want it.
There's got to be some reward.
There's got to be some of being driven
is you gotta have something to show for
it.
So we gotta be really careful that the
amount of wealth that you spread around,
if you spread it all around,
you're going to end up with no one
wanting to achieve anything.
Yeah.
Like I hear bernie sanders talk and he
seems like a really nice guy and he
seems like he really has his mind in the
right place in his heart,
in the right place,
and this idea of democratic socialism.
See him talking to people.
I'm like,
well,
that's definitely better than being
greedy.
It's definitely better than being
corrupted by the banks.
corrupted by wall street and given these
bullshit phony speeches for hundreds of
thousand dollars in fucking over people
for profit,
but does that shit.
But does socialism really work?
It doesn't seem to work.
It doesn't seem to like work in terms of
humAn motivation doesn't even work for
bernIe sanders who has multiple homes.
I mean the guy's got multiple ones.
You just bought our house for $800,000.
And what does he open that up to?
The public to come and stay in his house
because.
No,
of course not.
So it it.
It's sold out.
It's different.
Different thing at garden.
This money surfing the people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly right.
You did it and that money and if you
want to go out and buy that second home
on a lake,
good,
good for you,
bernie,
but don't try and you know,
make it like that's like,
like that's okay to take everyone else's
money.
They will do to everybody else,
but not to me it doesn't work.
Well.
The concept of income inequality is
always strange because it's like,
well,
okay,
but you should,
you make the same amount of money for a
job that doesn't have the same amount of
importance.
If again,
let's just go aHead and straight up
answer for you know.
No,
you shouldn't.
If you got paid after 10 years of
medical school,
the same that you get paid to drive a
bus after you busted your ass and worked
hard and had to study and do all this
stuff to go to medical school and by the
way,
you built up a bunch of debt trying to
go to school.
Why don't you just become a bus driver
for innovation?
Can be financial relationship.
We hope when we.
You got to be.
We have to be careful that,
and of course there are people that
legitimately need help in the west.
There's people with with disabilities,
there's people with mental problems and
we've got to be compassionate and take
care of those people to the best of our
ability,
but we definitely watch out for,
hey,
let's steal everything from the people
that worked hard and give it to the
people that didn't.
Yeah,
it just doesn't seem like a good idea.
It seems contrary to what we know about
human motivation.
Basic human instincts.
Yeah,
and then where do you stop?
Where do you stop legitimately like
worldwide,
because we could distribute all them
money and wealth that we've built in
american distributed over the whole
world.
Well,
I think a better concept is figuring out
why there are pockets of extreme poverty
and how to mitigate those pockets of
poverty that have just been generation
after generation in certain
neighborhoods.
It just been extreme poverty and these
people that grow up there,
that's what they know.
They're sort of almost programmed Into
it because they're.
They're seeing it around them.
That is the paradigm that they,
they accept and it's very self limiting
in a lot of ways.
We don't see anybody escape where you
see very few people escape.
It's very.
You feel like,
you know,
resistance is futile.
Like what do you do?
You know there's a,
there's a.
I wish I knew the,
all the details of this,
but there was a native american tribe
and somebody I'm sure we'll will tell me
what it is,
but there was a native american tribe in
northern California that when all the
native american tribes got designated as
native american tribes and they got,
you know,
here's what you're going to get and this
is your tribe and this is these guys.
FoR whatever reason,
they didn't get it.
They didn't get designated as a native
american tribe.
They just got,
they got passed over.
No one noticed them and now all the
members of that tribe like completely
dominate dave,
ron,
everything.
Financially,
they own everything up there.
They,
they kind of kicked ass.
Right?
And it's Because they had to.
And I think a lot of times when when
people just get given stuff,
it becomes a very,
very difficult for them to say,
you know what,
I'm going to go out and work hard,
you know,
am I going to bus?
Yeah.
That's a classic example of hey,
am I going to bust my ass at mcdonald's
for eight bucks an hour,
40 hours a week or whatever,
thIrty hours a week for nine bucks an
hour,
I'm going to work that hard doing that.
Or am I just going to take my welfare
check?
Which is equal to or almost equal to for
sitting around doing nothing.
But that's not a hard questIon to answer
for many,
many people.
Yeah.
I'm going to sit around and do nothing.
So we had to be careful that it's hard.
Yeah,
it is hard.
It's,
it is a natural inclination that people
have to do the least amount to,
to just be as comfortable as possible or
as lazy as possible.
You know,
I think your,
your statement that you always say
dicicco discipline equals freedom.
People should have that shit tattooed on
their thigh.
You know,
you should look at that when you get up
in the morning,
you put your underwear on like it's.
That shit is so important because if you
do have discipline and if you do go out
there and get the things done that you
need to get done,
you have freedom and you feel better and
you feel relaxed because you're not.
You don't have that balloon hoverIng
over you,
that balloon
of you know,
just knowing that you're not doing your
best knowing that you're not out there
hustling and if you just get a free
check every month and they don't really
have to go out there and kick ass,
you can kind of get by.
Boy that doesn't.
It's not.
It's not conducive to lighting that fire
under your ass that you need to be
successful.
And again,
I'm going to point this out for I think
the second or third time today.
I'm no sociologist,
I don't,
I'm not some big guy that understands
the mechanisms of the welfare state and
all that.
I'm just going off of what?
When I think,
which is similar to what you're saying.
Look,
if I was just getting a check for not
doing anything,
I wouldn't feel good aBout it.
Yeah,
I wouldn't feel good about it.
And so I think that there are people
that go,
hey,
if I can get free money,
I'm going to take the free money.
You know,
there is a concept of universal basic
income.
That's kind of interesting though
because this idea is that once we get
automation and once we get an artificial
intelligence that there's going to be so
many Jobs that don't exist anymore,
that we've got to figure out what to do
with all these people and the idea is if
you just have your basic needs taken
care of,
like not enough so that you could
actually thrive,
But just we have food and shelter.
How many people would then pursue their
actual love and what they're actually
passionate about and would it be the
city.
There's,
there's tests they're doing,
they're doing on it now.
They're trying to find out would the
same amount of people be successful,
would more be successful or would less
like how many people would pursue their
dream if they knew they didn't have to
worry about starving to death,
they just got money every month they
got,
they knew where they were going to sleep
and eat and then they could just go and
do whatever the fuck they want to do.
Or would that just squash motivation?
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't know what the answer is.
I'd say what I think.
I think.
I think it's squashed as motivation for
some.
Would it for you if you got a check
every month for like 12 grand or 12
grand for the year,
whatever it is.
Like I think that's the idea.
So you give people like a thousand bucks
a year or a thousand bucks a month.
Thousand bucks a month.
Yeah,
maybe double that.
Just enough that you could just get by.
But you know,
you're not boiling.
Two questions.
Number one,
of course would add what I take free
money.
sure.
Would I feel good about it?
No.
Number two,
where does that money come from?
Right?
Where does it come from?
Because that's the thing that I also
explained to my kids is that,
you know,
every time you,
every time the government gives a dollar
to somebody,
they took that dollar from somebody
else.
Yeah.
So,
and It's,
you know,
it's,
that's the reality of it.
Yeah.
Then the question is like where like
when a guy like bernie madoff or some
crazy wall street character,
when they just moved some money around
and make money,
lIke,
okay,
how much you get out of that?
Like where's that coming from?
Whose,
whose money was that?
Like,
where's that guy?
Where's that going?
And it has it.
How does it exist?
Well,
bernie's a bad example,
right?
Because he was stealing everyone's for
the best example.
Who,
well,
okay,
I'll give you that.
That uh,
but again,
those people are formulating companies
and funding companies
that are trying to grow and build and
create things.
You know,
that that money,
it moved somewhere and it ends up,
you know,
investing in a company and building a
company.
That's what,
that's what,
that's what America is,
right?
Yeah,
trying to build things,
trying to make things.
Yeah,
taking risk.
I wonder what is going to happen though
when all these fucking robots.
One is the uh,
the automatic driving cars,
trucks because that's a huge,
you know,
you go to vegas,
I was thinking about this when I'm in
vegas and you go to the buffet and
there's like 10 billion pounds of food.
None of that food comes from vegas.
All gets trucked in there.
So at some point all those trucks can be
driven by robots and that's not too far
in the future at all.
I think they're already doing it in
Australia already have automated trucks
in Australia that are driving,
you know,
shipping things around.
It's going to get weird.
Get real weird between that and genetic
engineering and all these different
things that we've been talking about.
This kid could get really weird.
And I think again,
going back to the original conversation
we started off with today,
I think the weirder it gets in the
further we get away from primal sort of
existence of hunting down food and
fighting against other tribes.
I think the further we get away from
that,
the more we're going to have to reach
back to it and ground ourselves to it.
Well,
at the very least,
the more you're going to have to deal
with whatever requirements your body and
your mind have for difficulty.
I think we have requirements for
struggle and difficulty because I think
your body is set up to it.
I think Jay,
biologically we have certain
expectations for difficulty and when you
don't uncover those oryx encounter those
expectations.
I think people find like a real lack of
meaning and in this lack of stress and
this piece and that's why we're going to
have to reach Back to this physicality
at some point.
And it's a good.
It's not just physicality or like you're
saying,
it's a mental struggle too.
It's trying to achieve things.
It's trying to.
When it's trying to be competitive,
if I'm just sitting there and I don't
have a job anymore and I just get,
you know,
12,000
bucks a month and that's enough for me
to pay my food and pay my rent and I'm
just going to sit there and play video
games.
I don't think that's the kind of
existence I would want to live in.
Might not even just be physical too.
I think it's just in overcoming and
enduring and figuring things out.
Like even writing a book,
I'm sure you're feeling like you just.
You have a new book out the way of the
warrior kid and I'm sure the feeling
that you get when you write a book and
completion completed is I fucking did
it.
I made that happen.
I didn't want to get through all those
days.
There was a lot of times I didn't want
to write,
but I got through it and here it is.
There's a satisfaction of accomplishing
goals and overcoming obstacles and
problems and if they don't have to be
physical,
I think there's mental requirements that
we have as well.
Yeah.
I think when people aren't mentally
challenged,
they just start to fade and if you're
not looking for the physical and the
mental challenges,
you're going to start to fade.
So you goTta be careful that why'd you
write this book?
Well,
if it's a kid's book way of the warrior
kid,
and the reason I wrote it is because
first of all,
all the things that we're talking about
right now,
they're happening even to kids.
I mean you have kids,
right?
Ipads,
iphones,
they're sucked into technology and
there's nothing completely wrong with
that.
but if they get sucked into technology
and they don't ever come out of it,
you got issues.
And being a kid,
if you remember,
and a lot of people forget this.
Being a kid is hard.
Being a kid is hard and in this
particular book there's a kid,
his name is mark,
he's in fifth grade.
he's got kind of the typical issues that
a fifth grader has.
He can't do any pull ups.
So in gym class when they're doing pull
ups,
he's getting made fun of he's doesn't
know is timestables,
which you should absolutely know in
fifth grade.
But he doesn't know him,
so he's thinks he's stupid now he
doesn't know how to swim because he
never learned and he's when they go on
the field trip to the,
to the lake,
he doesn't know how to swim.
So everyone's having a good tIme and he
can't.
And eventually they call them out on it
and finally is getting picked on by the
big bully.
Kenny williamson,
fucking kenny.
Kenny,
kenny williamson.
So it lasted.
The book starts off last day of school.
Basically.
All these problems come to a head.
He's all bummed out,
cryIng behind the library,
goes home and when he gets home,
his mom reminds him that his uncle,
uncle jake is coming to stay with him
for the summer.
And uncle jake is a guy that was a seal
in the seal teams and he's just got out
of the seal teams and he's going to go
to college in the fall,
but he's going to spend the summer with
his sister and his nephew mark.
And so you know,
the,
the navy seal shows up.
Uncle jake shows up and he sees his
little nephew and he says,
hey,
you know,
either actually staying in the same room
and he says,
hey,
you know what going to do tomorrow.
You want to go play some ball with you
want to go for a swim?
And the kid says,
you know,
I don't want to play ball.
It's not fun and,
and I don't know how to swim and don't
really breaks down,
you know,
getting picked on the whole nine yards.
And his uncle says,
okay,
so you can't swim.
You don't know your times tables,
you can't do any pull ups and you're
getting picked on.
We can change all those things.
We Just have to get a plan,
put it together and make it happen.
So it puts them on the workout program,
teaches them how to study,
teaches them how to swim,
teaches them jujitsu.
If it was only that easy and what's
what's good is it's not as hard as
people think.
And I think that's why the Book's
getting strong reaction because there's
actually pragmatic methods in there on,
for instance,
I went through all this stuff.
Not knowing,
not knowing timetables.
I went through that with my daughter.
My oldest daughter didn't know her times
tables and what she thought was,
she's stupid.
She thought I'm stupid.
I don't know my times tables.
Other kids know him.
I don't know him.
And I said to her,
you know,
she's crying,
this isn't whatever,
third or fourth grade crying,
what's wrong?
I'm stupid.
Why do you think you're stupid?
I don't know my times tables.
How much have you studied them?
I haven't studied them.
Well,
how do you think you're going to know
him if you haven't studied them?
What do you mean studying?
Boom.
Make flashcards.
An hour later she knows her times
tables.
It's that and so I actually go through
that method in the book.
How do you learn how to fight?
You're getting picked on.
You go down to your,
your Jujitsu school and you started
learning to jitsu and you and I both
know,
if you know jujitsu in a great school
fight in sixth grade,
you're goIng to win a 100 percent of the
time.
Right?
So you learn,
do you learn that?
Learn how to swim,
how do you,
how do you do that in?
His big thing is he's afraid of water.
Well,
why are you afraid of the water?
How do you overcome that fear?
How do you overcome fear?
You got to inoculate yourself to it.
You start off wading in the water,
then you don't your head.
Then you get,
you know,
then you eat.
Then you lay down and you feel the water
all over your body and then eventually
you step in and then eventually you
start to dog paddle and then eventually
you start to swim and then eventually
jumped off the bridge.
so these are real things.
That's how you overcome fear and that
you know,
that one I got from my,
my middle daughter who wanted to be in
the school play,
but she got stage fright and so she
would freak out every time she would
have to go in front of a crowd.
So I said,
okay,
we're going to inoculate you to being in
front of people first.
You're going to sing in front of me and
then you're going to sing in front of me
and mom,
and then you're going to sung in front
of me and mom and your brothers and
sisters,
and then you're going to sing in front
of you know our friends that are Gonna.
Come over.
There's going to be 10 of them,
and then you're going to sing in front
of you know all of the people that we
know at a block party and then you're
going to get out and you're gonna do
your rehearsal,
and she did it and she got a knock
related and I'll tell you right now,
she's not afraid of anything that girl,
and so that's the saMe thing that that
he goes through in the book,
overcoming his fear of water.
He inoculates too.
It gets used to it,
and then finally the final step is you
have to go right that you can't overcome
every part of the unknown.
You have to.
There's always gonna.
Be someone known in doIng something that
you've never done before and then what
do you do when you prepared as much as
you can?
And you've done all the training that
you can do,
then you've got to step up and you got
to go.
So that's what the book's about.
And I wrote it so that kids can apply
these things that I learned both in the
seal teams and in raising my own kids
they can apply into to their life.
And the reaction's been great.
It's been great to see all these kids
reading it and all the great feedback of
kids doing pushups and pull ups and and
training and going down and starting
jujitsu and making flashcards.
It's awesome.
That is awesome.
And then one of the cool things about
being a kid is,
well,
it's hard.
It's a struggle in that you haven't
really achieved any success yet in
anything,
but what you don't realize is that
you've got all these possibilities to
get good at stuff like once you become
really good at something.
One of the real problems is people don't
like to get out of their comfort zone
and to become a beginner again though.
And it's one of the beautiful things
about life is humbling yourself with
something new.
Humbling yourself and learning stuff and
kids,
they don't have that lesson yet,
so everything is terrifying,
but once they do learn it,
if you could teach a kid how to get good
at one thing,
like one of the things that led me to
get good at standup comedy and all the
other things that I did is that I got
really good at martial arts young.
So I knew,
okay,
I sucked when I first started,
I remember sucking,
but I remember I kept working and I get
good at it because I focused and I put
the time in.
Well if I just do that without anything
else you've learned that you,
you can make a path,
you can do it,
it can be done.
And that's,
that's,
you know,
that's kind of one of the main points of
the book.
And when the kid finally does his 10
pull ups,
that was his goal and his uncle says,
you know,
do you understand what this is about?
And tHis kid says,
you know,
well,
it's about,
I can do pull ups now.
And he says,
no,
this is about everything about
everything that you want to do in life.
You're going to have to work for you,
you're gonna have to come up with a
plan,
you're going to have to have the
discipline to execute that plan and when
you do that,
you're going to be able to achieve what
you want to achieve.
And that's hard work.
Hard work and discipline is what's going
to get you there.
And probably a lot of kids don't have
anybody in front of them like jocko to
tell them.
Well,
and you know what,
it's interesting.
So in this book,
you know,
uncle jake is the character and he
actually addresses that in the end of
the book because uncle jake leafs and
the kid says,
hey,
you know,
you're not going to be around anymore.
Who's gonna?
Who's gonna lead me?
Who's going to help me train?
And he says,
you didn't need me then and you don't
need me.
Now you know what you need to do.
You know what's going to take hard work.
And the other thing that I did in this
book,
which is I,
I played around with the idea,
but his dad,
the kid's dad is not really present and,
and the reason I did that is because a
lot of kids these days don't have a data
round and he,
the only thing he says about his dad,
I put one line in there about his dad,
which was,
you know,
he says my dad's gone a lot for his job
and stuff that that's the only line.
So you Have an idea that the kid knows,
his dad knows that he's out there,
he's working or doing whatever he's
doing.
But there's a lot of kids out there that
don't have a dad,
they don't have an uncle jake.
And that was another reason why but
wrote the book because kids need to see
and learn.
You know,
if you wouldn't have done martial arts,
who would have told you that,
hey,
if you work hard and you train,
you're going to get good at this.
That would've,
if you would've done that with martial
arts,
you wouldn't done it with stand up
comedy.
You wouldn't have done it with the rest
of your career.
You would have said,
you know,
you would've gotten on the stage the
first time for,
for,
for standup comedy,
you wouldn't have made anyone laugh.
You would have walked off set,
I suck and gone and got the job,
you know,
down at down at 7:11
or whatever,
you know.
that's.
Whereas if you,
if somebody said,
look man,
of course you suck.
You just started.
Of course you suck.
Of course you don't know your times
tables.
How would you know him?
You don't bond with that information.
Of course you're not good at standup
comedy.
You just did it for the first time.
You got to learn how to do it.
Of course you're not good at standup
fighting taekwondo.
You've never done It before,
so you got to learn these things.
You got to put in the work.
You learn that lesson through martial
arts.
A lot of kids don't get that
opportunity.
I'm trying to give them that opportunity
to learn that with this book and even
for people that aren't kids like,
go do something you're not good at.
It's really important.
It's good.
Just try something,
pick up a new hobby,
pickup a new discipline,
try learning how to play chess.
Try to just do something you suck at and
let let your mind feel what it's like to
be at the beginning stages of
improvement.
Again,
I think it's very invigorating.
Not only that,
I mean factually that's good for your
brain.
You know,
they say you're supposed to learn new
languages,
learned to play chess,
learn to play guitar,
read new books.
You're supposed to do that stuff your
whole life to continue.
That's what contInues to keep.
Just like your body falls apart.
If you don't exercise it,
your mind falls apart if you don't
exercise it as well.
Yeah,
I definitely feel that if I don't do
anything new for a long time,
I feel stagnant,
but when I start doing something new,
especially something that I'm not good
at,
so I start thinking about it a lot.
I started obsessing about it a lot.
I get invigorated.
I get excited about going there.
Yeah,
and we.
And we saw the same thing like when our
first book came out.
It's a leadership book,
right,
and everyone thinks,
hey,
you know,
it's another leadership book and then
when you read it,
people go,
oh,
wait a second,
this is like a new thought.
It's,
it's a new thought I haven't seen before
and we'd have these.
We have these things that we do where we
bring people in.
Like it's usually we go out and work
with a company,
we go out with one company and we go out
and we work with a company,
but we found that there were some
smaller companies or people that
couldn't afford to bring us in.
So we said,
okay,
what are we going to do about that?
So we made this thing up called the
muster where we open it up to the public
to come and you know,
come and spend two days going through
all these principles and it's the same
thing that you're talking about.
THey say it's a challenge,
it's new thought.
It's thinking about suffering from a
different light.
People that had been in leadership
positions for five years,
10 years,
15 years,
and they go,
oh,
okay.
I can apply this new methodology that I
haven't seen,
hadn't thought about before,
so they'll continue to grow and learn is
just so important across the board.
Yes.
Stepping outside of your comfort zone is
just one of the most important things
for a human being.
For whatever reason.
I mean,
I don't know what it is,
but I know what works.
Thanks.
And that's it.
That's what it is,
man.
For me,
I'd like to.
I've got a bunch of shit that I do that
I suck at right now.
It's,
it's so important,
man.
I just started running really recently,
like within the last couple of months
I've noticed that you've been posting
about that dude.
I suck at it and I'm fuck,
I'm.
So.
It's crazy.
But you're getting a lot better.
A lot quicker though,
man.
Like your endurance jumps up quick,
like within a few weeks I was able to
like way past areas.
Like,
I've got this,
um,
this trail that's about two point seven
miles through the hills,
like real steep hills and there are some
spots where I was just fucking dying and
now I can get through them and I can get
through them and get to the top and I'm
still dying,
but I'm dying less time in yourself too.
So I'm trying to make the times.
And,
and then,
you know,
uh,
I just started wearing a heart rate
watch to which,
uh,
I'll let my heart rate get down.
Don't like when I,
when I,
uh,
when I have to take a break on these
hill sprints,
I'll get my heart rate down to 1:40
and then I'll start going again.
People asked me that too because when
you get bored,
when you get bored of working out and
also when you reach your physical
limitations rights or you will reach
your physical limitations on something,
you know,
like you're going to get down to a six
minute mile,
let's say.
And then for you to take it past the six
minute mile,
you're going to have to like stop
lifting kettle bells,
get all skinny,
you know,
you'd go to a point where you are now,
that'd be your sole focus and I know,
I'm guessing you wouldn't want to do
that.
I know I wouldn't want to do that.
And so for me,
I'm always jumping around from Canada
from goal to goal,
right?
Like I'll,
maybe I'll be doing pull ups,
heavy pulse,
pulse,
pulse.
So I was trying to get up my max pull
ups and then I get to a point where,
okay now I'm,
I,
I'm not going to,
it's going to take every bit of focus in
my life to get to from from 58,
pull ups to 62.
I don't want to do that.
So I'm cool with 52 and now I'm going to
start working on my dead lift or I'm
going to start training jujitsu more.
I'm at and I'm just constantly 52 pups.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But like,
you know,
kipping pull ups,
not,
not just full dead hang.
Pull up.
How many full dead hang pull ups.
Can you do it?
I don't know.
Probably 30 something.
Damn,
that's a lot.
Are you,
uh,
do you do any,
do weighted ones at all?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I do wait.
But the waist belt or do you use a vest?
I have a weight belt and vests.
So I have like,
you have all set up in your basement,
is that what I'm looking at it?
Yeah,
it's my,
it's my garage,
my garage,
which is you have a house.
Jim wright.
I mean it's a game changer.
I hate to say it because not everyone
can can make that happen and people live
in cramped quarters.
But man,
if you can even just get a pull up bar
and it may be a set of rings.
You can do so much.
And then he grab yourself one kettle
bell.
if you have a yard and you have a
kettlebell,
you could do a lot for sure.
Pull,
pull up.
Bars are so gigantic.
Well not really.
All you need for a pull up bar is a
ceiling.
No,
that's why I mean,
I mean it's so gigantic.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
And also it's so good for your shoulders
just to hang out,
you know,
at the end you're back.
Yeah.
But if you have a pull up bar in your
house,
you can do pull ups,
you can do pushups,
you can do squats,
you can do,
you know,
all kinds of burpees and everything
else.
Sit ups and got work and you can pretty
much get your whole body in really good
shape with that one piece of equipment.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
So when you set out your workouts,
do you,
do you write them down on paper?
Do you just have an idea what you want
to do?
I do write them down because I kind of
logged what I'm doing,
but I'll put down whatever exercise I'm
going to do or whatever,
a bunch of exercises I'm going to do and
I'm logging down what I'm,
you know,
what my times are if I'm going for time
or what the weights are,
if I'm going for weight and I'm,
I'm pretty.
I heard this the other day,
so I'm gonna say it.
Um,
they said arnold was an instinctual
trainer,
so I do that somewhat,
you know,
I'm not like looking at a book and I
don't plan out for three weeks or a
month in advance of exactly what I'm
gonna do on that day because that day I
might go damn it,
you know,
I'm not feeling that type of workout and
I'm,
I need to not do it.
I'm going to do something else.
So I use my,
what my body's telling me somewhat.
That's not to say that I go,
hey,
I don't feel like doing anything to do
today so I'm not going to do it because
that's actually a rule that I have.
If I don't feel like doing something
today,
I feel like I need a rest.
I'll do something that day and put the
rest off to the next day.
Make yourself do it today.
And then if you still need it tomorrow,
you can take a rest.
But you can't take a rest today.
Not allowed.
Ooh,
interesting.
Do that to yourself.
You're your own boss.
So when you write your stuff out,
do you have like log book to keep
like a so you could go back and track
progress and you look at yourself?
Yeah.
So like say if you're going to work out
tomorrow,
do you plan it out tonight?
Nope.
I know kind of what I'm going to do
tomorrow.
Tomorrow I'm going to do a bunch of ring
dips.
I'm going to do a bunch of dips.
I'm going to be doing a bunch of a
parallel pushups.
I'm going to do a tone of burpees and
probably some that's going to round it
out right now.
I have a little tweak on my knee right
now so I can't sprint.
I'm like,
I normally would,
but otherwise I do be doing some sprints
in there too.
Yeah,
jujitsu tweaks,
right?
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
it was fucking joints.
IT is in.
But if you think about how much time you
spend on the mat,
if I would have been playing basketball
or playing soccer,
I'd still get the same worse.
Probably worse,
relatively injury free and this is not a
bad tweak.
It's just like,
oh yeah,
we'll tweak.
Well,
that's one thing that I try to impart on
people too,
that like strength and conditioning
training,
particularly strength training.
It protects the joints for sure and the
back and a lot of other issues.
I think that is why I have been
relatively knock on wood injury free
because two reasons I work out all the
time and I never take any significant
amount of time off.
I never say I'm not going to work out or
I never just fall into a hey,
I went through months or even two weeks
or even five days for me to for me to
not work out for five days.
There was some kind of like something
happened.
I was like majorly sick or I was.
Even if I'm traveling I'll still get it
done.
But I think that that consistency,
your body just is used to it and you
don't,
you don't get hurt as often and you're
like a hardcore metal guy.
Right?
Like what are you listening to?
I listened to.
So I grew up on the east coast listening
to old school.
Hardcore music.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
so metal and hardcore bands like the bad
brains,
a cro mags,
agnostic from just old school,
hardcore bands from,
from.
Yeah.
From john.
Joseph is a trip to the cro mags.
Yeah.
He's a fucking trip,
man.
I watched this documentary about him and
he's in his fifties,
tapes up his ankles and shit before
shows,
like he's warming up and stretching out.
Does triathlons in between shows,
right.
Wrote a book called meat is for pussies.
hardcore vegetarian.
Hari krishna.
Yeah.
I did.
The other guy,
the guy that founded that band,
the chromatics,
he's a,
he's actually a buddy of mine.
He's a jujitsu guy.
It's a black belt in jujitsu,
but he,
he's,
he's had a completely insane life as
well.
His name is harley flanagan and he,
his life's been completely insane,
isn't it?
Doesn't even really a doesn't mean
there's hardly.
There's hardly a picture.
Yeah,
he's mad.
I actually,
it was interesting because I just had
him on my podcast and it's,
it was a different,
you know,
guest for me,
a different genre and people,
you know,
first of all,
the guy,
you know,
people that listen to my podcast,
they expect a certain type of podcast,
right.
I'm going to talk about leadership,
I'm going to talk about the military and
all of a sudden I bring in this guy who
has been a complete maniac and I mean
he's done,
you know,
he was drugs,
drugs,
sex,
rock and roll.
It's basically been his whole life and
since he was 10 years old,
he was playing in a punk rock band in
New York city.
Shit,
he was,
when he was 10,
he was smoking.
Fuck where his parents,
his mom was a hippie.
His dad was a roamer.
Never,
never,
never met his dad.
And he is just,
he just grew up in the streets of the
lower east side in New York.
Did you go to New York city in the
eighties at all?
Very little.
I found a tournament in New York in the
19 eighties.
I remember driving there with some of
the guys from boston,
we were driving to the city and looking
at it going,
what the fuck is this place in New York
in the eighties is completely different
than it is now.
It was really,
really bad.
It was filled with crime,
like 42nd street down in times square
and when I was a kid I would go there
because I was into this kind of music
and dancing hardcore shows and metal
shows and you'd get off the train and
you get out in 40 secondary there'd be,
you know,
every two steps,
drugs,
dust,
crack,
everything and.
but that's where he grew up basically
without parents.
and then he's got to just,
just a crazy,
crazy story.
How old is he now?
He's 50.
He's still tRaining,
still just teaches kids class at hensel
kids' instructor.
It ends up race in New York.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Yeah,
that's cool.
But it was interesting because I had him
on the podcast and it was interesting to
have people that listen to it,
that listened to my podcast,
which is very different,
you know,
you bring in basically all kinds of.
You could get all kInds of such a
completely wide variety of people in
here.
My guests have been basically war guys,
right?
Ryan,
stan,
tim kennedy,
jody mitic was canadian sniper wounded
real bad in Afghanistan.
I had a guy named colonel william reader
on there who was a pilot in Vietnam,
got shot down and got shot down twice,
actually captured in Vietnam,
was in captivity for a year and he's
talking about he's in a,
in a bamboo cage with his leg shackled
and he wakes up in the middle of the
night because the rats are eating his
wounds.
I mean,
I'm bringing on guys that are just
talking about not only talking about
heavy subjects,
but they're also talking about it from,
you know,
a very positive perspective of life.
Right.
I mean,
is there anyone more positive than,
than brian stanford,
right.
Guys,
just like a,
just an amerIcan hero.
Right.
And so then I all of a sudden out of
left field,
I bring on harley flanagan and he tells
his story.
It was really interesting to me to have
people's reactions.
And there was a couple of people that
are like,
oh,
you know,
this was a real let down for you to
bring them on.
But if you hear his story,
you listen to the whole podcast mean.
Here's a guy who,
who you can hear it in his voice,
like his,
his hardest broken over some of the
things that he's been through in his
life.
Losing his father.
And his father was a,
was a heroin addict.
And,
and his father died,
burned alive in a dumpster as he lit a
fire to try and keep himself warm.
Oh,
that's died.
I'm buried.
His mom.
I mean,
it's just,
it's just a tragic story.
But my point is that the,
even though I had very few people that
were like,
oh,
that was,
you know,
you shouldn't have.
He swore literally,
hey,
he swore a bunch on the podcast that's
inappropriate or whatever.
And then I was really that,
that was kind of,
well,
that's,
that's kind of too bad to hear,
hear someone say that,
that they would have that viewpoint.
But what was really cool,
it was all these other people that are
very straight laced,
kind of kind of middle road,
american people that listen to podcasts.
We're lIke,
dude,
thanks for having that guy on what a
heart,
what a guy.
And it's good for me to know about that
stuff and it's good for to hear someone
that's been through the depths of drug
addiction and hell come back out of it
and do all right.
And,
and again,
from my perspective,
I think that my interaction with those
kinds of people when I was growing up,
which I certainly had,
you know,
I was a young kid,
go into New York and boston going to
hardcore shows and all that.
It'll let me see part of the world that
most people don't really see.
And so when I got in the military,
I got.
It was kind of used to dealing with
people that people aren't used to
dealing with.
And I think it helped me out a lot.
So is it a hard managing expectations
once you don't mean how many?
What do you do?
You have like 75 episodes up already?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Last time you here you had zero.
I love it though.
Getting after it and it's a lot of my
podcast is a lot different than yours
because I'm going deep on some subject
that I'm actually going to like I have
to study and prepare for and it's not
interacting with another person most of
the time.
Most of the time I'm interacting with
history so it's,
it's harder for me to prepare.
Now.
Of course you've been preparing for this
podcast for 50 years,
right?
I mean that's what you,
you've been mentally preparIng for
getting your experiences in your
background.
But I have to like dive into stuff and.
And so it is hard.
My,
my,
my point is yes,
it's hard for me to do a podcast a week,
I've got to read it.
But is it hard to manage expectations?
So I was getting after like.
Because once you establish like a fan
base,
sometimes they have this idea in their
head of what the podcast should be to
them,
like what they want out of it,
and then they,
they can express that they don't like
where you're going,
like,
I don't like that you brought this
harley guy on,
this guy's not what I like.
I like straight laced military guys who
don't swear this guy's a fucking nutty
dude.
Jumps around on stage.
And the,
my answer to that is no.
And I'll tell you why from the beginning
of say know when you said it was you,
it was you and tim ferris,
you know,
both you guys said you should do a
podcast.
And I said,
okay,
cool.
To this day,
your podcast with tim ferriss,
one of my all time favorite podcasts.
I listened to it in a,
in my.
I was,
I was cooking,
I was listening to my kitchen.
I was like,
jesus fucking christ.
It's a good podcast.
It was intense,
you know,
and it was a,
it was so deep and intense and I was
like,
I gotta I gotta talk to this dude.
I got to get you one because I had known
you like from peripherally dean's fights
and I'd seen you around,
but I didn't know who you were.
Didn'T know your story until tim had
john.
Yeah.
In it.
And so you know tim again,
when he,
when he pressed stop on the,
on the,
on the recorder,
he said you should have your own podcast
and then you told me in the middle of
the podcast you should have your own
podcast and obviously when you two guys
are telling me I should have my own
podcast,
I'm being a complete idiot not to listen
to you.
Well you did.
Now it's a huge success,
which is hilarious.
I love when people listen.
Everyone listened to joe.
Listen to me about everything.
Be selective often wrong,
but as I've done it that
I've done,
you know what I want to do and if people
don't like it that that's okay.
I'm okay with someone saying,
hey,
you know what,
you're.
You know I did.
So I've done some episodes that were
horrible,
man.
I talked about the mee lai massacre.
If you don't know what that is,
the meal,
I'm asked her,
you know,
people talk about these atrocities that
americans commit all the time.
Americans don't actually commit
atrocities all the time,
but we have committed some heinous
atrocities in this one is well
documented Vietnam,
the mili massacre.
It was a company of soldiers going into
a village and they raped,
murdered,
killed around 500 people.
Just cold blood.
I mean it's,
it's heinous.
It's awful.
Probably the hardest podcasts that I've
done because I'm a patriotic guy and
here I am talking about,
you know,
american soldiers doing heinous acts to
innocent people and,
and so,
and I've done that.
I did,
I did a podcast aBout the genocide in
Rwanda,
which was,
if you don't know anything about that to
tribes,
and it's very hard for americans to
understand this.
The difference between these two tribes
is nothing.
It's just two tribes.
They speAk the same language.
They have the same,
they look the same.
They have the same religion,
which by the way,
the religion was catholicism because
they'd been converted to catholicism.
Well,
they went on a rampage and the hutus,
which was one tribe,
murdered 800,000
tutsis in 100 days with machetes with
machetes.
So I've covered these dark and horrible
things on my podcast and,
and I,
and I don't even know really 100 percent
why other than this thought in the back
of my mind that I've always had,
which is that you have to kind of
understand the darkness of the world in
order to appreciate the good in the
world.
And that's why it was really interesting
to hear you talking to Jordan Peterson
because he covered that part.
You know,
he was saying,
look,
man is got a dark side and you won't
become a good person unless you
understand your dark side.
and,
and it's interesting for me because
Jordan Peterson is clearly have a highly
intellectual and academic guy and I'm
not right.
I'm,
I'm a nug,
right?
I joined the military after high school
and,
and yet so many of the things he says,
when he says them,
I say,
oh yeah,
well that's the same thing I stumbled
upon.
He came across that reading the the
french philosopher or whatever,
and that's where he comes in.
I came across it in life and so it's
very interesting to me when I hear him
say,
look,
there's darkness in the world and
there's evil in the world and we have to
face that,
and,
and as soon as I heard him saying that
on the podcast,
I'm like,
well,
that's.
That's what I think and I can't give you
the philosophical basis for it like he
can.
But I can tell you what I've lived
through and I can tell you that if you
don't understand the fact that there's
darkness in the world and that people,
human beIngs are capable of evil things.
If you don't understand that,
you're not going to understand the,
the,
the first of all,
you're not gonna understand what you
need to look out for in the world and
what we need to be aware of as a society
and as a,
as a race of humans,
but also you're not going to appreciate
things in the world that are beautiful
and good and positive.
So with the podcast,
I'm not doing it to make people happy,
I'm not doing it to make people listen.
I'm not even doing it to make people
listen.
I'm doing it because it's things that
I've lived through.
It's things that I want to understand
better and I'm going to keep doing what
I'm doing.
And if people like it,
then that's awesome.
And if people don't want to listen to
it,
that's cool too.
Well,
at least from my personal experience,
listening to guys like Jordan Peterson
or listening to yourself or listening to
anybody talk about really deep,
important subjects.
Even if you know what they're saying to
be true,
it reinforces It in your own mind and
maybe even opens up new doors of
comprehension.
Jordan certainly did that with me when I
was listening to him talk.
Like he was saying some things like,
you know,
like,
uh,
like talking about dragons and dragons
have gold.
I was like,
whoa,
jesus christ.
Like he was.
He was.
He was hitting some notes about human
psychology and the reason why we behave
in certain ways and the pitfalls of
these certain types of behavior that I
absolutely knew he was right,
but and maybe I'd even thought about
them before,
but seeing them reinforced so eloquently
and seeing express so articulately,
it really like it.
It sparked life in my mind.
Yeah,
and even know he was talking about being
a warrior,
right,
and how these guys in modern times,
we don't.
We don't spend time being a warrior.
If you and I were living in 500 years
ago,
you and I would both be battle scarred
and we would be used to that lifestyle.
People aren't used to that lifestyle
now.
They've kind of forgotten what that
feels like and so I'm.
That was my life.
I mean that was my life was to prepare
for war and go fight war.
That was my whole life.
And so for me to look back on it noW and
here,
Jordan Peterson to say like,
that's normal.
That's okay.
That's expected,
and it makes me say,
okay,
I understand now were kind of part of
part.
I understand myself better when I hear
him say,
oh yeah,
this is this normal for guys to go out
and fight wars.
This is the warrior mentality and when
you come back and you tell the truth
about it,
people will react to that in a positive
way.
That's what he was saying about.
He was like,
hey,
look,
you're not,
you're not some,
you know,
academics sitting there reading a book
and in talking about what you're reading
in the book,
you're like,
no,
I live.
I'm a fighter.
I fight.
I've been through this stuff.
I've had physical challenges.
That's why people are listening to what
you're saying,
you know,
because you have that warrior mentality
in your life.
Well,
I think that guys like Jordan Peterson
and I think that anybody that can tap
into those truths that we know,
you know,
uh,
I just don't think we hear them enough.
I think we're inundated with so much
stupid shit every day.
It's so hard to get to any like,
real substantial truths that will
positively affect your,
both your outcome and your,
your outlook on life.
And I think you guys like you guys,
like tim ferriss is putting out all
these amazing podcast,
Jordan Peterson,
all these people that can express things
to someone like this podcast literally
has changed my life.
I mean it's changed my thinking.
It's shit.
I'm a d,
a totally different person than I was
when I first started this podcast
because talking to all these interesting
and fascinating people and wise people,
it's been like having some crazy crash
course in a million different
disciplines and a bunch of different
conversations and seeing the pitfalls of
some people's thinking and,
and,
and being around people where you see
the holes in their,
the way they express themselves or the
way they process information.
And it made me recognize the holes in my
own processing and the way I used to
communicate with people.
I'm just,
I'm a better.
I'm a better conversationalist now.
And it all comes from just having these
intense conversations.
This,
this whole podcast thing is something
that I never expected in life.
I never expected it was going to come
along.
When it came along.
I never expected it would be something
that I would do and I never expected it
would be something I consume as much as
I do.
I don't even have radio anymore in my
fucking car.
No.
I listened to music.
If I listened to music and my music that
I get off itunes or it's something that
someone like a new band that someone
tells me returns,
it turns me on too,
but I don't listen to anybody.
Like I don't listen to satellite radio.
I don't to local radio.
I listen to podcasts constantly.
One hundred percent and there's
something that is.
And I know even I experienced so.
So I what?
I'm 75 podcasts deep.
It's been going for a year and some
change,
but when people come up to me now they,
they look me In the eyes and they shake
my hand and they know me.
They know you and I kind of know them
too.
Like they have these shared experiences
with me and I talked about this on that,
on that podcast about Rwanda.
They talk about the fact that the first
thing they do in a revolution in a coup
is they want to take control of the
radio and there's this great piece in
there where he says,
they're talking about the fact that with
tv you have to take what the image on
the screen in your mind,
your eyes process it,
and then it goes into your brain with
reading.
You take those words and they go in
through your eyes and it processes.
It goes into your brain,
but with audio there's no filter.
The words are going directly into your
brain where they're unfiltered and so
it's this.
That's why I think this podcast audio
format is so powerful because the people
that are listening to this right now,
they're sitting in the room with us.
They're here with us and when I'm
recording my podcast,
I'm actually talking to them and they're
there and when I go out and I meet
people,
you can absolutely feel like,
hey,
and that the little inside jokes.
Because even though my mom talking about
how dark and evil my podcast is,
where we have a good time to.
When we have episodes that are funny and
we talk about regularly,
we talk about jujitsu and food and
everything else working out and we,
we,
we have fun too and all those little
inside jokes people will say the inside
jokes to me that I never met this person
before but,
but he knows exactly what I'm talking
about and,
and so it's,
it's a very,
very powerful medium that I think got
skipped over and we went from radio just
completely absorbed into tv and then
absorbed into the internet and now all
of a sudden we got to this other side
where we're back to this thing that
there's some reason why people used to
sit around that radio and listen to
those radio shows back in the day.
Even I did,
you know,
when I was a kid for whatever reason,
I liked radio shows.
Listen to dr demento,
dr sharma,
dr.
yeah.
I would sit there and listen to dr
demento and they'd have those little
radio shows and those skits and that was
a powerful medium and I knew it back
then and so for,
for me,
like you,
you know,
as soon as,
as soon as you and tim were saying you
should do your own podcast.
I was absolutely,
I'm going to do this and I'm going to
every,
you know,
my goal is that when people press play
on my podcast,
I want them to like be putting their
headphones on and like stretching their
neck a little bit,
pressing play and then,
and then just going,
okay,
this is,
I want them to get absorbed in it.
That's my goal was well there's also
nothing else like it in terms of like
that you can have,
you only have one guy you work with,
right?
Echo charles.
Yup.
So it's you and him and that's
it.
Like there's not like a whole team.
If you had a,
the,
the audience that you have,
I know that you guys are a shit ton of
downloads now.
So the,
that kind of audience,
if you are on a radio show,
you'd have a successful radio show,
so you'd be in a studio somewhere,
you'd have a network behind you,
you'd have to have production meetings,
you'd have to have a bunch of people
that would tell you what the thought was
going to say.
I'd have people telling me what I could
and couldn't say.
People telling me to stop or do an
advertisement right now and we'll know.
And that's the beautiful thing about it
and you know,
I know we're leaving money on the table
because right now all these advertisers
that come to us and they say,
hey can you talk about this and can you
talk about that and can you.
And they want to pay us money.
And I'd just like,
nope,
we're not doing it.
We have one we have on it because it's
your,
your boys,
your company.
And you helped me in the beginning.
So.
And good products.
But that's it.
That's all.
That's the only advertisement we have
not doing anybody else.
And so there's no one that can tell me
what to do a lot.
That's a beautiful thing.
There's a lot to that.
There's a lot to it and also not
interrupting your podcast is giant.
Not ever.
Never breaking up that thought.
Just keeping that thing going to the
end.
Say thank you very much.
See you guys next week.
Boom,
and I just think that people get locked
up in this is sort of like almost like a
trance of the way you're thinking there.
They're in jockos mind,
you're talking and they're thinking how
your thinking.
They're like allowing themselves to be
taken on this journey,
whether they're in their car,
whether they're at the gym,
they're absorbed in your thoughts in a
very unique way and because of the fact
there's not a whole lot of other people
contributing in it and entering into the
picture,
you know,
like producers and network executives
and advertising agencies and look,
we've looked at the stats and john go,
you've got to talk more about this.
And you know what I mean?
You could geT lost in analytics and
never find your true voice,
but podcasts,
it's almost entirely your true.
It's so it,
it's,
I don't want to say low tech,
it's not low tech,
but it's low.
There's a small amount of voices,
you know,
in terms of each individual podcast.
it's just your voice and if maybe like
mine,
it's mine and the guest and whoever else
comes in,
that's it.
There's not a lot of other Intrusion and
that's where you mean singular visions
is what makes some,
it's like there's a reason why netflix
does so well.
And the reason why a lot of these hbo
shows dose well is because they leave
those people alone.
They just go make,
uh,
make us game of thrones will be back
here.
Go ahead.
What are you gonna do you're gonna make
a comedy special.
You know,
I did my last comedy special with
netflix.
They have fucking zero notes for me.
Zero.
I've never done a goddamn thing where
they didn't say,
you can't talk about this.
You can't put that bit in and can see
the only thing I've ever done where they
said we love it.
Like that's it.
Yeah.
Do it.
Go kick ass.
Okay.
Like,
literally that was it.
I love that joke.
You're going to do that one.
I'll do it.
Yeah.
I actually told that to my publisher
about my publisher.
I was like,
you know what?
The best thing about my podcast is is
that no,
I can do whatever I want to do.
I can whatever I want to do.
And that's what makes it.
It's very,
very liberating.
There's no control mean you write,
write a book,
you know someone's going to edit that
thing,
they're going to change this and they're
going to adjust that and they want the
cover to look like this.
The podcast is,
it is just you and you know,
even the first,
my first podcast came out and you know,
my wife lifts.
I've listened to it and she was all
stoked because when was the last time
that you sat down and talk,
just talk to your wife for two and a
half hours,
right?
It doesn't happen and my wife was like,
hey,
where's awesome?
Like she got to know me better.
I do it for 20 years.
She got to know me better because she
got to sit and listen to me talk for two
and a half hours and now she,
she's listening to every single one of
them and she's.
She knows.
She actually knows me better than she
did before the podcast started because I
got a wife and four kids and jobs and
have bork and travel and all that.
She,
I don't have time to sit there and talk
to my wife for for two and a half hours.
Hey,
maybe I'm a bad person,
but that's just the reality of life.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
Honestly,
when do you ever get a chance to sit
like this across from someone and talk
to them for three hours without checking
your phone or that anybody coming into
the room without anybody interrupting
you with something you have to do or
someplace you have to be?
it's very odd.
It's.
That's one of the things that I say.
One of the reasons why I say that it
changed my life is because it educated
me on other people's thought processes
in a way that you just don't.
You don't get one on one dialogue with
people.
If you think about it,
you know,
as we talk about going back to these
primal things,
there's a primal thing about having a
human conversation and if you think
about where technology is going,
we don't have much human conversation.
So you're a hundred percent right.
Not only might not having two and a half
hour conversations with my wife,
I'm not having two and a half hour
conversations with anybody,
anybody until I come up here and sit
down with you or until I go into my
podcast studio and I sit down and I have
it a two and a half hour conversation
with,
you know,
a million people that are going to sit
there and listen and they're going to
give me feedback on twitter and they're
going to tell me this and they're going
to tell me their story.
And it's,
it's very,
it's,
we're filling a hole.
I think it was a hole in communication
right now because you know,
we text each other,
you know,
you and me text each other.
I text,
I text echo,
I texted everybody,
texted my wife,
think you and I've ever had a
conversation on the phone.
No,
no,
that's the word we're living in.
People just text.
It's just weird.
It's weird.
I'm like legit things.
Hey,
I gotta send you something.
Here's,
I just pull them out just like that's
the way it is and it's totally
acceptable,
but there's something missing and if we
can't,
you know,
the next level is like,
well we're going to roll.
You know what I mean?
Like that's the next thing is you
trained together.
but there's,
there's a,
there's a gap and in human contact right
now.
But in having conversations,
and I'm just thinking of this right now
that this,
the whole nature of podcasting fills
that hole and if you look at the
podcasts that do well,
it's podcasts that are conversational
list.
Unless you go with the podcast,
it's highly
produced and they got they,
you know,
because like radio lab,
all of those ones that are highly
produced and even the ones that are
produced by,
you know,
npr,
so they have real money behind them and
they're there.
They're a different thing,
but for normal dudes that are just
sitting around and talking,
those are popular podcasts.
That's why tim,
sam harris,
those guys are sitting around and
talking and explaining stuff because
that doesn't exist anymore in the in the
day to day life.
For a lot of people,
you know what else doesn't exist in a
day to day life,
a place where it's okay to be a man.
It's actually okay to be a man.
It's okay to have thoughts like
everybody is so,
so toned down and neutered.
it's like human resources and corporate
life has watered down people's natural
behavior to the point where people are
just dying on the inside,
sitting in these fucking cubicles
rotting.
Just freaking the fuck out.
Having all these thoughts,
they can entertain having to pretend to
be someone there.
They are not all day long putting on
this bullshit way of talking,
this fake way of thinking.
Everybody's got to subscribe to whatever
fucking ridiculous policies their
company wants to enforce and you're just
a robot and you get out of there and you
just want to scream or you want to
listen.
To some guys talk about some real shit.
Real shit.
Yeah.
And then go,
fuck.
How come I can't talk about real shit?
you know,
it's another reason why I wrote the kids
book because the kid's book,
instead of it being about,
hey,
if someone's picking on you,
go and tell the teacher.
It's like,
no.
actually if somebody's picking on you,
learn to defend yourself and kick their
ass if needed.
That's that.
That hasn't been said.
It's another reason I wrote the book.
I,
I've toLd this story before,
but I went and got some book for my kid
when he was little.
My,
my one son and three daughters.
I went and got a book from ms.
It was like a pirate book.
Right?
And I'm thinking,
cool pirates are going to burn stuff.
Takeover villages or steal things.
This will be awesome.
And I read the book and it's just
complete.
These guys are complete,
you know,
pathetic.
They're pathetic.
They're not fake.
Pirate,
fake.
They're not manly pirates.
Right.
And I just was so embarrassed by some.
I don't even check check.
I threw it away.
And you can't learn from a pirate that
you got to go out and crush some things
sometimes.
Then we got to just check ourselves
because guess what?
Life is.
That's what life is.
That's another thing that we shield kids
from these days.
Life is hard.
You don't get a trophy.
You don't get it.
There's no such thing as a trophy for
participation.
That's fake.
It's a lie doesn't exist.
You can't learn your times tables.
Guess what?
You need to work and study.
You don't get put into a special class
and get a tutor and maybe you get a,
you know you got some special help to
get.
No,
you need to work and make that happen.
You don't know.
Don't,
don't know how to swim.
Guess what?
That doesn't mean you stay away from the
water.
No,
you learn how to swim.
You step up,
you man up.
That's what you do.
So that's another reason why I wrote the
book so that people can actually.
Kids can learn that
life is hard.
And in order to deal with life,
you got to be hard.
Yeah.
And just this idea that life is hard.
Something you're supposed to shield from
them.
It's so silly and you know,
I've had this conversation with my
friends because everybody that I know
that's interesting how to fucked up
life,
but,
but now we have kids and the last thing
we want is our kids to have a fucked up
life.
So we put our kids in these good
schools.
We live in these nice neighborhoods.
Everybody eats healthy and there's no
fucking domestic violence and everybody
seems it's,
it's so different than all of our lives.
And we were talking about it,
me and brian calendar actually talking
about it like,
look,
we all have fucked up childhoods and
everybody we know had fucked up
childhoods and they're all interesting
but I don't want my kids to be boring,
but I also want them to be safe.
So it's like,
how do you,
how do you approach that?
I think you'd get involved is what I've
chosen to do is get my kids involved in
martial arts and and,
and,
and give them the opportunity to pursue
difficult things and understanding that
through pursuing these difficult things
like in accomplishing stuff like you,
you learned something about yourself.
You learn that you have this ability
inside of you to overcome.
I've got this statement that I made on
my podcast about kids and I said,
if you're helping your kids,
you're hurting them and if you think
about it,
right,
and the example I gave is like tying
your kids' shoe.
If you tie your kids' shoe,
you're,
you're actually taking away the
opportunity in their life to develop
their fine motor skills of tying a shoe.
You're actually taking that away from
them.
And it's the same with everything.
Make your own sandwich,
make your own bed,
clean your own room.
You need to do this stuff for yourself
and when I'm helping you,
you're hurting you.
So I think we can.
I think we can protect them without just
completely coddling them and then making
sure that every issue that ever could
present itself to them has been
eliminated because you're gonna end up
with some kids.
Yeah,
and if those kids have to compete with
some kid has had to take care of himself
their whole life,
that kid's gonna be ferocious.
yup.
Yeah.
You're going to have a feral kid
competing against.
You're a little soft fleece lined kid.
Yeah.
No,
that's,
that's why some of those competItive
sports are,
are so important.
You know,
whether it's an martial arts are great,
wrestling is great jujitsu,
but you know,
football,
basketball,
anything thing that puts you in those
challenging positions where you're going
to have to step up,
you're going to get ground out.
And like my one of my daughters
wrestles.
Well yeah.
And she is,
you know,
this is the same one that got stage
fright and to see her step up and you
know,
we live a pretty good life,
right?
I mean it's,
we live in southern California,
we live in a nice house.
It's,
it's,
it's a nice living.
Right?
it's a very comfortable situation.
Some of the hardest times that she's
been put through is on the wrestling mat
and having to step up against some girl
that like the exact girl you're talking
about.
Some girl from the barrio in san diego,
that's a tough ass girl that's been
through the ringer and has domestic
violence going on at her house and her
one escape from all that is to come out
and wrestle against some other girl and
beat her down.
So my daughter has to step up and
do that.
And it's,
it's an incredible thing.
It's,
it's,
it's incredibly powerful and empowering.
Even I watched her change,
you know,
and when she would be intimidated by in
those situations to where now she's
like,
bring it,
bring it.
I got something for you.
That's awesome man.
Um,
we were almost three hours in here.
So anything else that you've got a
whole,
this,
you're the only guys ever showed up,
I think with this many notes.
Yeah.
Well,
so what I want to do is now if we can
spend the next four hours going through,
we,
we hit it,
we hit all kinds of stuff.
Yeah.
I was driving up here taking notes on a,
on the Jordan Peterson podcast.
I think that everyone should listen to.
That's a great,
great podcast to listen to and there's
so many points that he covers in there
that are really profound and I think
important important today,
but he's dealing with a very unusual
situation where those coddled soft kids
are now in universities and they're
trying to run the show with these
ridiculous programs of inclusion and
diversity and you know,
forcing their mindset down everybody
else's throat.
It's really fascinating.
It's a fascinating and disturbing to see
all that happening and it's really.
Yeah,
it's,
it's actually disturbing to see that
happening and see kids could be focused
on such important things in the world
and they ended up focusing on something
that is borderline in many cases,
borderline,
you know,
meaningless.
You know,
launch,
let's,
let's move towards a real goal.
There's diseases to cure and you know,
good things to do in the world.
Well,
you know,
I think everybody agrees that racism is
bad and homophobia is bad,
but that's not exactly what you're
dealing with here we're dealing with is
people trying to control the way other
people behave and talk and think and it
might not even be in response to any
actual real like negative things that
have happened.
It's like they're trying.
They're trying to create negative things
to battle that might not even be there.
It's just a lot of weirdness today in
this world and I think that to bring it
back full circle,
a lot of this weirdness comes from a
lack of true struggle.
Like,
do you think That these kids that are
growing up in Russia,
they're doing back flips off of the top
of buildings?
Are they dealing with the same like,
uh,
you know,
diversity lectures and classes that they
have to handle it.
I think there's an,
there's an intrinsic part of human
beings that wants to be part of a tribe
of some kind and wants to defend their
tribe.
And when you grow up in a place where
there's no real try,
but then you look for one to latch onto
and these people over here,
they have a cause and they've got a
tribe and you can be part of that tribe
and you can be.
And then you can lash out at the bad
guys.
And I think that happens a lot.
And I Think it's a,
it's unfortunately unfortunate because
it really crushes,
you know,
individuality,
which is what I,
you know,
that's my kind of my premier base,
faults are around individual freedom to
be an individual thing for yourself,
for your mind.
Yeah.
There's a lot of comfort in those groups
that these people belong to.
Whether it's,
You know,
any kind of group,
whether it's a hardcore right wing
group or a hardcore left ring group you
get in,
you kind of know what the rules are and
you play by those rules.
And then you surround yourself with a
bunch of likeminded people and an echo
chamber who also support the fact that
these rules are the rules and we have to
get these out there.
And like,
we,
I think we just need to establish
there's a bunch of shit you shouldn't
do.
Don't steal from people,
don't rape anybody,
don't,
you know,
don't shoot anybody,
like figure out a way we can
harmoniously get along together without
fucking with each other,
you know,
and then just let everybody be whatever
they are.
If you're gay,
you're gay,
if you like listening to classical music
and,
and running naked through the streets,
I don't care.
It's still fuck me,
just don't,
You know,
don't cause trouble,
don't you know.
And again,
that's just,
you're talking about individual freedom.
Be yourself,
man.
You know what's,
which is what I like individual freedom
to do what you want to do.
Hard for insecure people to allow that
to happen.
Because in insecure people,
when they see individual freedom that's
contrary to what their own personal
behaviors,
like they have to question themselves
and challenge themselves.
So they decided that that person's wrong
and these people are wrong and I'm right
and this and this needs to be
established and we need to fight and we
need to go out and punch nazis or
whatever the fuck they think they're
supposed to be doing.
And it just gets real weird man.
It's weird than when that becomes your
whole life and I'm sure you get this.
I get it a lot,
which is people on social media that
want me to weigh in on this thing or
they want me to weigh in on this side or
they're attacking me because of this or
they're attacking me because of that.
Not so much attacking,
but people want me to weigh in on things
all the time and it's things that I just
say,
man,
this isn't affecting me.
And,
and not only that,
my comments aren't goIng to move this
forward.
And finally I don't care about that
thing.
I understand that you're obsessed with
it,
but I'm not,
I don't.
I'm not obsessed with this thing that
you're obsessed with,
so I don't even care that you're
obsessed with it.
That's cool.
And when people asked me,
hey,
sounds good,
go keep,
keep,
keep doing what you're doing.
Sounds great.
Not not my thing.
Move on.
People get obsessed with things that
they won't even be obsessed with a few
years later,
like,
hey man,
I got obsessed about that thing that you
are obsessed with.
And now I'm like,
you know,
man,
I'm not even obsessed about that
anymore.
I'm onto some new shit.
Go get obsessed with kettlebells in
jujitsu.
You start that out.
Get obsessed with life improvement.
Find things that you enjoy doing that
are difficult.
Do them and get better at them.
It seems so simplistic.
It seems like a ridiculous,
idealistic point of view,
but it's effective.
you will be happier and you will be a
more positive influence on everyone
around you.
Yeah,
for sure.
Be nice to people.
Not so hard.
Jocko willink.
Ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
tell everybody how they can get your
podcasts.
Podcast jocko podcast is the name of the
podcast.
it's available everywhere.
New book is called way of the war kid.
Old book is called extreme ownership.
You can get those everywhere.
they sell books,
the muster,
which is a leadership event in
austin,
Texas.
Then we got one in sAn diego.
Extreme ownership.com
for those too.
I'll see you on the interwebs.
Thanks john.
Go on instagram and check out his watch.
Jocko willink.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
we'll see you soon
later.